LIKE TO CONVENE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
RESPONSE IN PREVENTION --
WELCOME EVERYBODY --
TODAY OUR AGENDAS SHORT BUT
MEATY ARM OR WE'RE GOING TO
BEGINNING TO BEGIN WITH THE
PRESENTATION.
OF THE RESULTS OF OUR WORKPLACE
CLIMATE SURVEY --
A FROM TALON KEEPERS OUR VENDOR
AND IT'S OF I'M SURE GOING TO BE
VERY INTERESTING FOR US TO SEE
HOW OUR EMPLOYEES.
I'M FROM ALL ACROSS THE SPECTRUM
OF PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR THE FOR
IN THE LEGISLATURE FROM DISTRICT
STAFF TO PEOPLE IN THE BUILDING
TO PEOPLE ACROSS THE STREET.
NO LEGISLATIVE OFFICE BUILDINGS
FEEL ABOUT THE PLACE IN WHICH
THEY WORK AFTER THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE MOVING ON TO THE PROPOSAL
FOR A RECOMMENDATION OF FOR THE
RECOMMEND HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR THE CHANGES IN OUR POLICY
DEALING WITH SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE --
FOR THAT --
I SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL OR VICE
CHAIR AND SENATE REPRESENTATIVE
AND MYSELF WILL PRESENT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ALL OF YOU.
FOR YOUR FEEDBACK --
AND YOUR SUGGESTIONS AND AGAIN
NEXT WEEK TWO THIRDS THURSDAY
I'M SORRY ON THURSDAY WHICH WILL
FEEL LIKE NEXT WEEK TO MANY OF
US -- TO
FORMALLY ADOPT OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN SEND
THEM OFF TO SENATE JOINT RULES.
SO WITHOUT ANY DOES ANYBODY HAVE
ANY.
DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY COMMENTS
THEY'D LIKE TO MAKE BEFORE WE
MOVE TO THE CLIMATE SURVEY.
ALRIGHT WITHOUT WE'RE GOING TO
BE MOVING TO CHRISTOPHER
MULLIGAN IS THE CEO OF TALENT
KEEPERS [inaudible]
WELCOME.
DATING EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT AND
BUILDING A FAIR AND INCLUSIVE
CLIMATE WILL REVIEW THE RESULTS
OF THE SURVEY.
AND REVIEW SOME RECOMMENDATIONS.
OUR PURPOSE IS TO CREATE A FAIR
ACCEPTING AND OPEN CULTURE THAT
WOULD BE FREE FROM
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT.
WE WANT A MEASURE ORGANIZATIONAL
CLIMATE IDENTIFY STRENGTHS AND
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND THEN RECOMMEND SOME ACTIONS
TO IMPROVE CLIMATE AND REDUCE
INSTANCES OF REPORTED
HARASSMENT.
THE MODEL HERE REPRESENTS WHAT
THE LITERATURE SHOWS US OUR THE
COUNTRY CONTRIBUTORS.
TO A CLIMATE THAT EITHER FAIR
AND OPEN OR ONE OF HARASSMENT
AND WE HAVE OUR DEMOGRAPHIC
CHARACTERISTICS WHICH WOULD BE.
GENDER AGE ETHNICITY OR
SOMETHING WE CAN DO ABOUT THAT
WE HAVE OUR OCCUPATIONAL
CHARACTERISTICS IN TERMS OF ARE
YOU IN A SUPERVISORY ROLE NON
SUPERVISORY ROLE.
THE LOCATION IN WHICH YOU WORK
--
AND THEN WE HAVE ORGANIZATIONAL
CLIMATE AND THAT IS THE ONE
THING THAT WE CAN CONTROL.
AND WAS THE PURPOSE OF OUR
SURVEY.
AND ONE WERE ABLE TO MAKE
CHANGES TO THAT CLIMATE WE CAN
REDUCE THAT CULTURE AND WE GET
ALL THE BENEFITS AT THE BOTTOM
IN TERMS OF ITS SATISFACTION OF
OUR EMPLOYEES --
COMMITMENT TO THE ORGANIZATION
THEIR HEALTH THEIR ENGAGEMENT.
SO THIS IS A MODEL THAT WE'VE
CREATED A TALENT KEEPERS OVER
EIGHTEEN YEARS.
TO CHAU THE DRIVERS UP
ENGAGEMENT.
AND WE MEASURED THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF EACH ONE OF
THESE DRIVERS AND OUR CLIMATE OF
YOUR EMPLOYEES PARTS CLIMATE
SURVEY OF YOUR EMPLOYEES --
CREDIBLE LEADERSHIP.
IS A LEADER THAT I CAN TRUST TWO
IS A GOOD COMMUNICATOR.
WHO TREATS ME LIKE AN INDIVIDUAL
SOMEONE WHO I THINK HAS MY BACK
IF I NEED SUPPORT I CAN GO TO
THAT LEADER GET THAT SUPPORT?
SUPPORTIVE CO WORKERS I WANT TO
WORK WITH LIKE MINDED PEOPLE IF
I'M GIVING A HUNDRED AND 10% I
WANT TO WORK WITH OTHERS WHO
WERE DOING THE SAME.
JOB AND CAREER SATISFACTION Y.
DOING WORK THAT'S MEANINGFUL TO
ME THAT I THINK I'M GOOD AT AND
IS THERE A PATH FORWARD FOR ME
WHATEVER THAT LOOKS LIKE.
AND LASTLY A HIGH PERFORMING
ORGANIZATION AN ORGANIZATION I'M
PROUD TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH BUT
I BELIEVE IS DOING GOOD WORK SO
THE SO THE DRIVERS.
OF EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT AND AT
THE BOTTOM WE GET ALL THESE
BENEFITS OF COURSE THIS MODEL
WAS DEVELOP VERY BROADLY --
SO IN TERMS OF YOUR OUTCOMES
WILL BE DIFFERENT DUDE THERE'S
NO PROFITABILITY OBVIOUSLY FOR
THE LEGISLATURE.
UMPS WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
SOME DIFFERENCES.
NOW WHAT WE WANTED TO REALLY
FOCUS ON ARE THE ELEMENTS IN
THAT HIGH PERFORMING
ORGANIZATION DRIVER.
THAT REALLY CREATE A FAIR AND
INCLUSIVE CLIMATE SO WE CREATED
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THAT WOULD
FOCUS ON THAT PARTICULAR
ELEMENT.
THE SURVEY WAS ADMINISTERED.
FROM APRIL EIGHTEENTH THROUGH
MAY ELEVENTH OF THIS YEAR THERE
WERE TWO THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY ONE ELIGIBLE.
OF RESPONDENTS THAT INCLUDED ALL
BENEFITS ELLA TOLD POLICE
LEGISLATURE'S VOLUNTEERS AND
INTERNS.
AND OVERALL WE HAD A
PARTICIPATION RATE OF 46%.
DO YOU USE SOME BENCHMARKS IN A
SURVEY OF THIS TYPE WHICH IS AN
ANONYMOUS SURVEY OF CONTENT THAT
IS SENSITIVE.
WE COULD EXPECT PARTICIPATION
RATES BETWEEN THIRTY AND 50%.
SO TO BE AT 46% OF THE TOP END
OF THAT RANGE.
I THOUGHT THERE WAS A SLIGHT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE.
BUT GOOD PARTICIPATION GIVEN THE
NATURE OF THE SURVEY.
SO HERE THE FIVE ELEMENTS THAT
WE LOOKED AT IN THE SURVEY.
AND WE'VE RANKED ORDERED THEM
FROM STRONG GUEST TO LOWEST.
SO CO WORKER ENGAGEMENT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WAS THE STRONGEST
DRIVER OF ENGAGEMENT WE THINK
THAT'S AN OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU
CAN LEVERAGE GOING FORWARD.
AND THE BENCHMARKS THAT YOU SEE
ON THE RIGHT ARE OUR GOVERNMENT
BENCHMARK THESE ARE NOT ALL.
PUBLIC SERVICE BENCHMARKS ARE
ARE.
ENTITIES THAT GO TO THAT
GOVERNMENT BENCHMARK ARE NOT ALL
LEGISLATURE ABSOLUTELY VERY
GENERAL --
BUT YOU CAN SEE YOUR WELL ABOVE
THAT GOVERNMENT BENCHMARK WHICH
IT'S AT 69% SO 83%.
OF YOUR EMPLOYEES ARE ENGAGE
WHETHER CO WORKERS.
SECOND IS LEADERSHIP.
THEIR IMMEDIATE SUPERVISOR IS A
REAL STRENGTH FOR THE
LEGISLATURE --
THEY BELIEVE THAT LEADER IS
TRUSTING CONCERNED ABOUT THEM --
AGAIN.
AS A COMPARISON TO THE
GOVERNMENT BENCHMARK JUST A
COUPLE OF POINTS BELOW.
THE GOVERNMENT TARGET.
SEVENTY TWO JOB AND CAREER
ENGAGEMENT WE SAID 62% --
AGAIN A LITTLE LOWER THAN THE
THE BENCHMARK THAT WE HAVE --
WILL LOOK AT SOME OF THE
ELEMENTS THAT COMPRISE EACH ONE
OF THESE DRIVERS IN THE ENSUING
SLIDES.
AND THEN ORGANIZATIONAL
ENGAGEMENT REALLY BEGINS TO DROP
OFF AND AGAIN THAT'S WHERE WE
TYPICALLY SEE FAIR INCLUSIVE
ENVIRONMENTS FALLING INTO THAT
AREA SO JUST 40%.
OF THE RESPONDENTS WERE ENGAGED
BY THE ORGANIZATIONAL DRIVER AND
FINALLY THE FAIR AND INCLUSIVE
CLIMATE ELEMENT WAS EVEN LOWER.
AT 36% FAVORABLE.
SO WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
CERTAINLY IN THE BOTTOM TWO
AREAS AND YOU CAN SEE WE DON'T
HAVE A BENCHMARK FOR THE FAIR
INCLUSIVE CLIMATE.
ELEMENT THAT WAS UNIQUE. TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO THERE ARE SOME STRENGTHS
LET'S BEGIN WITH THOSE.
EMPLOYEES ARE SATISFIED WITH
THEIR WORK DUTIES AND ARE
COMMITTED TO THEIR WORK IN
PUBLIC SERVICE. 70% OF THEM ARE
SATISFIED WITH THEIR WORK
SATISFACTION.
I GENERALLY IS MORE
ENVIRONMENTAL IN TERMS OF THE
LOCATION IN WHICH I WORK OUT
THAT THE THINGS THAT I'M WORKING
ON THE NATURE OF MY WORK.
ENGAGEMENT IS DIFFERENT AND
THAT'S THE PEOPLE WITH WHOM I
WORK MY CO WORKERS BY LEADER.
OF THE PEOPLE THAT I INTERACT
WITH -- BUT
70% ARE SATISFIED WITH THAT
OUTSTANDING THAT'S A REAL
STRENGTH FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
JOB DUTIES WERE CITED AS THE
NUMBER ONE REASON EMPLOYEES ARE
STAYING IN THEIR ROLES THEY LOVE
THEIR WORK. 78% OF EMPLOYEES
INDICATE THE AND TEND TO STAY
WITH THE LEGISLATURE FOR THREE
YEARS OR MORE AND THAT IS
REMARKABLE.
IN OUR CURRENT ECONOMIC CLIMATE
WHERE THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS
AT RECORD LOWS THREE POINT 9% --
WE ARE NOT SEEN THAT TYPE OF
COMMITMENT AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS OTHER INDUSTRIES
OUR TURNOVER IS INCREASING.
AND SO THAT IS A VERY LONG
TENURED OUTLOOK FOR YOUR
RESPONDENTS.
AND LASTLY EMPLOYEES ARE
SATISFIED WITH THEIR HEALTH
PLANS AND BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE IS COMMITTED TO
DELIVERING HIGH QUALITY SERVICE
TO THE PUBLIC.
SO REAL STRENGTHS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
AN ADDITION I MENTIONED AT THE
DRIVER SLIDE THAT THERE IS A
REAL STRENGTH OF CO WORKERS AND
LEADERS SO 83% OF EMPLOYEES ARE
ENGAGED BY THEIR CO WORKERS --
WE THINK AGAIN THIS IS ELEMENT
THAT WE CAN LEVERAGE IN AS PART
OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND 70% WERE ENGAGED BY THE
DIRECT AND IMMEDIATE SUPERVISOR.
OVER 80% OF THEM.
BELIEVE THEIR SUPERVISORS
TRUSTWORTHY CARING AND LISTENS
TO IDEAS SO ANOTHER ELEMENT THAT
WE CAN LEVERAGE TO INCREASE THAT
FAIR AND INCLUSIVE CLIMATE.
IN TERMS OF OUR OPPORTUNITIES
EMPLOYEES DO NOT FEEL SECURE IN
THEIR JOBS AND DO NOT FEEL
RESPECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
SO ONLY 55% OF EMPLOYEES BELIEVE
INDIVIDUALS IN POSITION OF POWER
SUPPORT.
I HARASSMENT FREE WORK
ENVIRONMENT. 38% DO NOT BELIEVE
VICTIMS OR REPORTERS OF
HARASSMENT ARE FREE FROM
RETALIATION AND JUST A THIRD 33%
TO NOT BELIEVE APPROPRIATE
ACTION WILL BE TAKEN.
AFTER A COMPLAINT IS MADE SO
THERE ARE SOME OPPORTUNITIES
HERE -- TO
CHANGE THOSE PERCEPTIONS.
AND OF THOSE TO INDICATE THAT
THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED OR
WITNESSED HARASSMENT.
FEMALES REPORTED HIGHER
INCIDENTS OF HARASSMENT THAN
MEN.
THE PERCENTAGE OF SUPERVISORY
PERSONNEL WHO REPORT HARASSMENT
IS HIGHER THAN THAT OF NON
SUPERVISED IN SOME CASES DOUBLE
THE RATE OF REPORTING.
HOWEVER BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE NON
SUPERVISORY EMPLOYEES.
THAT THE NUMBER THAT REPORTED
HARASSMENT IN THE NON
SUPERVISORY ROLE IS GREATER.
THE MOST PREVALENT INDICATION OF
HARASSMENT RESULTED FROM
INTERACTIONS WITH LOBBYISTS OR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
AND CAPITAL EMPLOYEES REPORTED
HIGHER INCIDENTS OF HARASSMENT
THAN THOSE LOCATED IN THE TO SO
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A LOOK AT EACH
ONE OF THOSE DRIVERS AND THE
ELEMENTS THAT COMPRISE THEM --
AGAIN BE INDEX OVERALL FOR
ORGANIZATION ENGAGE WAS AT 40%
SLIGHTLY HIGHER FOR THE ASSEMBLY
THEN THE SENATE.
AND HERE ARE THE QUESTIONS THAT
COMPRISE THAT.
SO ONE ELEMENT OF THE
CALCULATIONS HERE IS THE TRUTH
OVERALL ENGAGEMENT INDEX IS NOT
AN SIMPLE AVERAGE OF THE ITEM
SCORES -- SO
THAT'S WHY THERE'S BELOW US ITEM
SCORES 44% OF THE INDEXES FORTY
THE MATH TO DO THAT IS IS AT THE
BOTTOM WE LOOK AT EACH
RESPONDENT.
AND OF THEIR AVERAGE RATING ON A
FIVE POINT SCALE OF AGREEMENT
WHERE FIVE TO STRONGLY AGREE.
IS THREE DOT SIX FIVE OR HIGHER
THEY'RE DEEMED TO BE ENGAGED SO
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
MATH BETWEEN THE OVERALL INDEX.
AND THE PERCENTAGES NEXT TO THE
ITEMS THE ITEMS INDICATE THE
PERCENTAGE.
OF RESPONDENTS HAD AGREED WITH
EACH OF THOSE STATEMENTS OR
STRENGTH IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSISTENTLY DEMONSTRATES.
DELIVERING HIGH QUALITY SERVICE
TO THE PUBLIC IS A HIGH PRIORITY
WITH 69% OF RESPONDENTS AGREEING
TO THAT.
MANAGERS ARE ACCESSIBLE
APPROACHABLE. 64% AND THEN WE
BEGIN TO FALL BELOW THE 50% RATE
WERE LESS THAN HALF OF THE
RESPONDENTS AGREED WITH THE
STATEMENT SO ONLY 49%.
AGREED THE LEGISLATURE SHOWS
RESPECT FOR EMPLOYEES. 45% I
FEEL I CAN QUESTION THE POLICY.
FOR PRACTICE WITHOUT FEAR OF
BEING PENALIZED AND 44%.
BELIEVE THAT THEIR EMPLOYERS
PROCESSED AND PROCEDURES TO
EVALUATE AND PROMOTE EMPLOYEES
IS FAIR.
SO THERE IS SOME OPPORTUNITIES
AREAS THERE.
YOU FEEL THAT YOU REALLY NEED TO
NOW.
WELL NEXT INDEX OR DRIVER IS THE
JOB AND CAREER ENGAGEMENT INDEX
--
62% EFFECTIVE OVERALL FOR
LEGISLATURE A LITTLE STRONGER
FOR THE ASSEMBLY THEM THE SENATE
--
82% LOVE THE CAREER THAT THEY'RE
IN.
THEY BELIEVE IN THEIR WORK IN
PUBLIC SERVICE. 78% BELIEVE THEY
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
DECISION MAKING AUTHORITY.
PERFORM THEIR JOBS EFFECTIVELY.
777% BELIEVE THEY HAVE THE
INFORMATION RESOURCES NEEDED TO
EFFECTIVELY GET THEIR WORK DONE.
TWO THIRDS 67% BELIEVE THEY HAVE
THE TRAINING NEEDED TO PERFORM
THEIR JOBS EFFECTIVELY.
AND 54% BELIEVE THEY HAVE
SUFFICIENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PROFESSIONAL GROWTH.
THOSE DATA ARE VERY CONSISTENT
ON THE PROFESSIONAL GROWTH SIDE
OF WHAT WE SEE NATIONALLY --
MOST EMPLOYEES WHO LEAVE THEIR
EMPLOYERS TODAY ARE LEAVING FOR
CAREER GROWTH OPPORTUNITIES --
NOT NAY CHAU YOUR PROMOTION AND
A RAISE BUT GROWING SKILL SET ON
EXPERIENCE SO YOUR DATA ARE VERY
CONSISTENT [inaudible]
WITHOUT FINDING.
THE CO WORKER INVASION INDEX 83%
OVERALL IN GAUGE WHETHER CO
WORKERS HERE THE SENATE.
HELLO HIGH HIGHLY A HIGHER LEVEL
OF ENGAGEMENT.
SO 84% OF EMPLOYEES BELIEVE
THEIR CO WORKERS COMMUNICATE
EFFECTIVELY --
THEY'VE RECEIVED THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO SUCCEED
AND THEY DEMONSTRATE INTEREST
AND CONCERN FOR MY PERSONAL WELL
BEING.
SO AGAIN THIS IS A STRENGTH OF
THE LEGISLATURE THAT WE BELIEVE
YOU CAN LEVERAGE GOING FORWARD
TO INCREASE THAT FAIR AND
INCLUSIVE CLIMATE --
AND FINALLY THE LEADER ENGAGE AN
INDEX 70% ARE ENGAGED BY THEIR
LEADERS SLIGHTLY HIGHER FOR THE
SENATE ON THE ASSEMBLY --
YOU BEGIN BEGIN AT THE TOP WITH
FEELING THAT THEIR SUPERVISOR
SOMEONE THEY CAN TRUST. 82%
AGREED WITH THAT THEY LISTEN
WHEN THEY HAVE SUGGESTIONS ON
HOW TO DO THINGS BETTER.
OTHER CONCERN FOR ME AS AN
INDIVIDUAL THESE ARE ALL VERY
STRONG ELEMENTS THAT ARE REALLY
REQUIRED AND AND MUST BE PRESENT
FOR ENGAGEMENT AND A FAIR
INCLUSIVE ENVIRONMENT --
THEY FEEL THAT THEIR SUPERVISOR
HOLDS THEM AND THEIR CO WORKERS
APPROPRIATELY ACCOUNTABLE FOR
PERFORMANCE THAT DRIVES A LOT OF
TRUST -- 76%
BELIEVE THEIR SUPERVISOR
PROVIDES FEEDBACK THAT CAN HELP
THEM TO IMPROVE THEIR
PERFORMANCE. 75%.
FEELS THEIR SUPERVISOR.
HELPS THEM FEEL EMPOWERED
INCREASE IN VIOLENT WHERE THEY
CAN MAKE DECISIONS. 73% BELIEVE
THEY CLEARLY COMMUNICATE
EXPECTATIONS AND THE REASONS
BEHIND CHANGING PRIORITIES.
AS 72% BELIEVE THAT THEIR
SUPERVISORS AWARE OF
GENERATIONAL DIFFERENCES IN THE
WORKPLACE IN RESPONSE
APPROPRIATELY.
IT'S ALL VERY STRONG ELEMENTS.
AND THEN ARE FAIR AND INCLUSIVE
CLIMATE INDEX 36% [inaudible]
ENGAGEMENT.
STRONGER FOR THE ASSEMBLY THEN
THE SENATE BY TEN POINTS OUR
BIGGEST DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO HOUSES.
BEGINNING AT THE TOP --
86% UNDERSTAND [inaudible]
THEIR EMPLOYERS.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION
POLICY. 72% ARE AWARE OF THE
COMPLAINT PROCESS.
AND THAT WE BEGIN TO DEPART FROM
THOSE VERY STRONG NUMBERS 255%
BELIEVE INDIVIDUALS IN POSITIONS
OF POWER SUPPORT HARASSMENT FREE
WORK ENVIRONMENT. 54% BELIEVE
THE LEGISLATURE HAS POLICIES AND
PRACTICES THAT PROVIDE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO STAFF REGARDLESS
OF MEMBERSHIP AND PROTECTED
CLASSES. 40% BELIEVE THAT IF
THEY REPORT HARASSMENT WITH A
WITNESS IT OR EXPERIENCE IT
THEMSELVES.
BY FOLLOWING THE COMPLAINT
PROCESS THAT APPROPRIATE ACTION
WILL BE TAKEN.
AND 39% ARE CONFIDENT THAT IF
THEY REPORT HARASSMENT WITNESSED
OR EXPERIENCED THERE WOULD BE NO
RISK OF RETALIATION. FOR
THEMSELF FOR THE VICTIM.
THE LAST ITEM WE WANT A LOWER
SCORE AND THAT IS I'VE HEARD
OTHERS MAKE JOKES OF WORK ABOUT
PROTECTED CLASS.
SO JUST 34% AGREED WITH THAT IS
WHAT WE WOULD WANT.
WE HAVE ONE OTHER ELEMENT BEFORE
LOOK AT RECOMMENDATIONS AND A
VERY COMMON METRIC IN.
INDUSTRY IS TO LOOK AT WHETHER
OR NOT YOUR EMPLOYEES.
STAKEHOLDERS WOULD RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE AS A GOOD PLACE TO
WORK TO FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
INSTALLED THE EMPLOYEE NET
PROMOTER SCORE.
AND IT'S THE ONE QUESTION THAT
DID NOT USE A FIVE POINT SCALE
OF AGREEMENT USED A TEN POINT
SCALE.
AND IF YOU RESPONDED ON THAT TEN
POINT SCALE WORST TENNIS I
STRONGLY AGREE.
YOU WERE CONSIDERED TO BE A
PROMOTER IF YOU READY THAT A
NINE OR A TEN IF YOU RATED THAT
A SEVEN OR EIGHT EIGHT YOU WERE
DEEMED TO BE PASSIVE.
AND SIX OR BELOW YOU WERE DEEMED
TO BE A DETRACTOR.
AND SO THE RANGE OFSCORES
RANGES FROM NEGATIVE ONE HUNDRED
TWO POSITIVE ONE HUNDRED OVERALL
FOR THE LEGISLATURE WE RATE
NEGATIVE THREE YOU CAN SEE THE
NUMBERS.
OF DETRACTORS PASSIVES AND
PROMOTERS --
THE GOAL IS TO BE AT THIRTY OR
ABOVE.
MODERATE IS CONSIDERED BETWEEN
ONE AND THIRTY SO NOT.
NOT ALL BAD NEWS THAT BAG OF
THREE OF THE GOAL IS TO MOVE OUR
PASSIVE TO PROMOTERS.
SO THEY CAN WRITE THAT A NINE OR
TEN AND OF COURSE SUCH A
TRACTORS UP AS WELL.
AND THERE WAS NO DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE SENATE FOR THE USE.
WHEN WE ASKED WHAT WOULD
INCREASE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE'S GOOD
PLACE TO WORK THE NUMBER ONE
MOST FREQUENTLY CITED ISSUE WAS
PAY?
FOLLOWED BY CAREER AND MANY
TIMES IT WAS CAREER GROWTH.
FOLLOWED BY LEADERSHIP
[inaudible] ONE OTHER.
SET OF QUESTIONS THAT WE ASK WAS
THE STRONGEST REASON THAT YOUR
EMPLOYEES.
CHOOSE TO STAY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
FOLLOWED BY ONE THING THAT WOULD
CAUSE THEM TO LEAVE IF IT
DOESN'T CHANGE SO STARTING ON
THE STATE SIDE --
DUTIES DOING WORK THAT MATTERS
WAS THE NUMBER ONE REASON CITED
24% OF ALL RESPONSES --
FOLLOWED BY BENEFITS CO WORKERS.
OTHERS THREE ELEMENTS ON THE
STATE SIDE THAT ARE VERY STICKY
PEOPLE TEND TO STAY FOR A LONG
TIME WHEN THEY STAY FOR PEOPLE
AND OPPORTUNITIES.
AND SO THAT WOULD BE OUR CO
WORKERS CAREER AND LEADERSHIP
CATEGORIES.
WHICH WILL FREE AGGREGATE THOSE
TOGETHER LOOKING ABOUT 37% OF
ALL STAY REASONS FALLING INTO
THOSE CATEGORIES SO WE'D LIKE TO
GET THAT HIGHER.
STRONGER WE CAN GET THAT THE
LONGER YOU'LL HAVE RETENTION --
ON THAT LEAVES SIDE PAY WAS THE
NUMBER ONE REASON WITH THIRTY
SIX POINT 7% OF RESPONSES
DEALING WITH PAY --
THE THEMES THERE WERE THE
FEELING THAT PAY MAYBE A LITTLE
STAGNANT --
AND THERE MAY BE SOME IN EQUITY
IN TERMS OF ONE PERSON DOING --
OR TWO PEOPLE DOING THE SAME JOB
AND ONE BEING PAID SOUP
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE FOR IT.
THE SECOND MOST COMMON WAS
CAREER AND THAT WAS LACK OF
GROWTH THEIR ADVANCEMENT.
AND FINALLY LEADERSHIP AND THAT
THAT WITH A HOSTILE ON FAIR WORK
ENVIRONMENT. ONE THING TO NOTE
IS WE HAD ABOUT.
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY SOME ODD
MORE STAY REASONS THEN LEAVE.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAID THERE'S NOTHING
RIGHT NOW WOULD COST THEM TO
LEAVE SO VERY HEALTHY TO SEE
MORE STAY RECENT INSTANTLY.
SO SOME RECOMMENDATIONS OF FIRST
RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE
REGARDING THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AND PROPHECIES THAT
YOU HAVE.
AROUND HARASSMENT AND HOW TO
CREATE A ACCEPTING UNFAIR OPEN
ENVIRONMENT.
ALSO WE RECOMMEND THAT THERE BE
A REVIEW FIRST TO ASSESS THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES.
AND THEIR RELEVANCE TO THE
CURRENT CLIMATE NOT KNOWING WHEN
THOSE WERE WRITTEN.
MAKING SURE THEIR CURRENT.
AND ARE THEY CLEARLY DEFINED.
SECOND WOULD BE TO RESET IN
TERMS OF EDUCATING EMPLOYEES.
ON WHAT APPROPRIATE AVENUES
THERE ARE TO LOG COMPLAINTS.
AND TO BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS ONCE THE COMPLAINT IS
MADE.
THIRD THEN WOULD BE TO EVALUATE
HOW WELL THOSE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES ARE BEING USED.
SO WHAT IS THE RATE OF USAGE.
HARM UNDER THE UNEMPLOYED
UNDERSTANDING THE PROCESS --
HOW WELL ARE THEY BEING EXECUTED
HARD TO FOLLOW UP STEPS THAT ARE
DEFINED IN YOUR PROCESS ONCE THE
COMPLAINT IS MADE ARE THEY BEING
FOLLOWED?
SO INDIVIDUALS ARE AWARE OF
WHERE THEIR COMPLAINT MAY BE IN
THAT PROCESS.
AND LASTLY ENFORCE THOSE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES WHICH IS
A BALANCE BETWEEN
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THE PROCESS
--
WITH TRANSPARENCY IN WHERE WE
ARE IN THE INVESTIGATION.
AND FOLLOW UP WITH THAT PERSON
WHO REPORTS.
THE SECOND AND THIRD
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE HERE I
MENTIONED SEVERAL TIMES THE
STRENGTH OF YOUR CO WORKERS 83%
ENGAGED BY THEIR CO WORKERS --
SOLUTION OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE
THAT BY EDUCATING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ON HOW TO CREATE
THAT FAIR INCLUSIVE CLIMATE.
MORE EMPLOYEES REPORTED THAT
THEY WITNESSED HARASSMENT.
THEN THEY REPORTED EXPERIENCING
HARASSMENT.
SO WE WANT TO HAVE THOSE
BYSTANDERS WHO WITNESSED THAT
TAKE ACTION.
AND BECAUSE OF THEIR AFFILIATION
FOR THEIR CO WORKERS THEY SHOULD
BE SO MOTIVATED.
AND SO WE WANT TO EDUCATE ALL OF
THE EMPLOYEES ON HOW TO
ANONYMOUSLY REPORT INCIDENTS
THAT THEY HAVE WITNESSED.
AND THE COURAGE THE EMPLOYEES TO
MAKE REPORTS.
THE THIRD RECOMMENDATION IS TO
BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT.
STEPS INVOLVED IN THE PROPHECIES
INCLUDING WHO WILL BE HANDLING
COMPLAINTS.
IN ORDER TO MITIGATE THAT FEAR
OF RETALIATION.
WE BELIEVE LEADERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MODEL.
HOW THEY SHOULD WORK?
IN TERMS OF BEING ACCOUNTABLE
FOR FOLLOWING APPROPRIATE
PROCEDURES AND CREATING A FAIR
AND INCLUDE INCLUSIVE CLIMATE
MAKE THAT A PRIORITY IN THE WAY
THEY LEAD.
AGAIN THE INCIDENTS OF OR THE
PERCENTAGE OF SUPERVISORY
PERSONNEL WHO REPORTED.
WITNESSING OR EXPERIENCING WAS
DOUBLE THE RATE.
OF NON SUPERVISORY PERSONNEL SO
WE WANT THEM TO STEP UP OF DAY I
HAVE WITNESSED.
OR EXPERIENCE THAT THEY SHOULD
MODEL THE APPROPRIATE RATE TO
REPORT THAT.
AND LASTLY WE WILL REASSESS
THESE METRICS WITH A FOLLOW UP
SURVEY ONCE THE LEGISLATURE HAS
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ENACT
CHANGES.
AND WHAT THOSECHANGES FLOW
THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
SO THAT WAS THE PRESENTATION
THAT I HAD PREPARED THIS
MORNING.
THANK QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THE
PANEL MUSTERED DAILY.
THAT YOU DON'T SHARE --
SO THE ONE I THINK THE THE THE
BIGGEST QUESTION FOR ME IS THAT.
FOR THOSE WHO DIDN'T
PARTICIPATE.
AND IN IT THERE WAS A REASON
THEY DIDN'T PARTICIPATE BECAUSE
THERE WAS FEAR.
THEN IT WOULD SKEW THE WHOLE
OUTCOME OF THIS --
SURVEY IF THEY DID IF THEY FELT
SECURE AND THE AND THE OPTIONS
WERE OR THE RESULTS WERE
DIFFERENT.
AND I KNOW THAT TIME IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET.
THEM TO BUY IT FOR EVERYBODY TO
PARTICIPATE SO THAT WE CAN
REALLY GET A A A A PER FREAKS
SURVEY.
SO I'M JUST IN MY OWN.
TIME OF LISTENING --
TO EMPLOYEES OF OF THE BODY.
THAT THERE WERE MANY THAT DID
NOT PARTICIPATE BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T TRUST THE SYSTEM.
SO HOW DO YOU --
I GUESS I'M TRYING TO GRAPPLE
WITH.
THE RESULTS IF FOLKS DIDN'T
PARTICIPATE BECAUSE THERE WAS
FEAR OF RETALIATION OR THERE WAS
NO TRUST TO WHAT AND IN
[inaudible]
IN OTHER.
S. CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE YOU SEEN
THIS BEFORE AND WHAT WHAT DO YOU
HOW DO YOU DO WHAT DO YOU DO.
TO GET PARTICIPATION IN IN A IN
THE ARENA WHERE PEOPLE HAVE
TRUST.
SO PARTICIPATION RATES ARE
ALWAYS A CHALLENGE THIS SUBJECT
MATTER IS EVEN MORE DIFFICULT.
GENERALLY EMPLOYEES WILL
PARTICIPATE IF THEY SEE VALUE IN
DOING SO.
AND THEY GENERALLY JUDGE VALUE
IN TWO WAYS.
FIRST DID THEY HEAR ANYTHING
ABOUT THE RESULTS OF THE FOR OF
THE SURVEY THE PREVIOUS SURVEY
IN THIS CASE WERE TRYING TO GET
PARTICIPATION UP IN THE SECOND
SURVEY.
AND SECONDLY DID THEY SEE
ANYTHING CHANGE AS A RESULT OF
THAT.
SO GOING FORWARD WE WOULD HOPE
TO SEE A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF
THE 46% WHO PARTICIPATED IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THOSE TWO ELEMENTS
COMMUNICATION OF THE RESULTS AND
THEM SEEING CHANGES BEING MADE
IN THEIR WORKPLACE.
WOULD DRIVE PARTICIPATION
HIGHER.
AND THE SECOND ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK IN TERMS OF THE CURRENT
DATA IT'S WHAT WE HAVE IT'S
WITHIN THE RANGE OF WHAT WE
WOULD EXPECT WHICH IS 3250% --
I THINK ALSO SUPERVISORY
PERSONNEL TALKING TO THEIR TEAMS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THE SURVEY.
ENCOURAGING THEM TO PARTICIPATE
ALL OF THAT HELPS [inaudible]
JUST.
IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR --
SO WHAT IF YOU HAD 30% JUST I'M
JUST PICKING A NUMBER.
IF YOU HAD 30% OF THE FORTY NINE
THAT DIDN'T PARTICIPATE.
WHAT WERE ALL IN AGREEMENT WITH?
THERE WAS NO TRUST THAT WOULD
TOTALLY CHANGE THIS.
THE THE OUTCOME OF THIS SURVEY.
IN.
IN WHERE WE SHOULD HEAD MAYBE
RIGHT.
I THINK THE DATA IN BE FAIR
INCLUSIVE DRIVER THAT WE THE
LAST WE LOOKED AT WERE WORKED
FAIRLY SUBSTANTIAL IN TERMS OF
THE ITEMS THAT WERE LOW.
I WOULD NOT SUSPECT THAT IF
THERE WERE ANOTHER 30% WHO
PARTICIPATED WHO DIDN'T TRUST
THE SYSTEM I DON'T THINK THE
DATA WOULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY
DIFFERENT.
I THINK THE ITEMS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THE RESPONDENT
GROUP AS THE ONES.
NEEDING ATTENTION ARE LIKELY TO
NOT HAVE CHANGED [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MS WALDRON.
EGGMAN -- TO
JUST ON THAT THE SCREEN THAT
JUST HAPPENS TO BE UP ON NUMBER
FIVE IT TALKS ABOUT EVALUATING
GOING BACK AND REASSESSING AND
WITH A FOLLOW UP SURVEY.
WHAT WOULD YOU RECOMMEND THIS
THE TIMING? FOR THAT I MEAN HOW
LONG ONCE WE'VE IMPLEMENTED IN.
YOU KNOW A YEAR SIX MONTHS YOU
HAVE LONGER THAN THAT AT WHAT
POINT DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD
START TO LOOK AT DOING A FOLLOW
UP.
WOULD SAY WAITING AT LEAST SIX
MONTHS AFTER ALL OF YOUR CHANGES
HAVE BEEN ENACTED.
ANYWHERE FROM THAT SIX TO TWELVE
MONTHS TIME FRAME AFTER THEY'VE
BEEN PLACED SO THAT THE
EMPLOYEES GET A CHANCE TO SEE
HOW THOSE ARE ACTUALLY PLAYING
OUT.
WOULD YOU RECOMMEND DOING THE
EXACT SAME SURVEYS YOU CAN.
COMPARE APPLES TO APPLES OR
WOULD IT BE CHANGE SOMEONE WE
KNEW TYPICALLY RECOMMEND THE
EXACT SAME SURVEY WITH A COUPLE
OF ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THAT ASK
ABOUT.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HEARD ABOUT
THE RESULTS OF THE FIRST SURVEY
HAD THEY SEEN THINGS CHANGE AS A
RESULT OF THAT [inaudible]
OKAY -- JUST
A JUST A QUICK FOLLOW UP.
WHEN NEAR?
OR ABOVE THAT IT'S TALKING ABOUT
EDUCATING STE.
CLOSE OF CLIMATE --
WHEN EMPLOYEES ARE WITNESSING
THINGS THAT ARE BYSTANDERS --
HAVE YOU FOUND OR HOW HAS IT
WORKED WITH YOU KNOW THE
TECHNOLOGY.
PEOPLE USING APPS TO REPORT
THOSE THINGS HAVE THEY BEEN
SUCCESSFUL I MEAN I DON'T.
THINK EVERYBODY IN THIS DAY AND
AGE IS.
YOU KNOW FAMILAR WITH ABSENT.
HOW THEY WORK AS COMPARED?
TO OTHER FORMS OF REPORTING.
YEAH FORCE I DON'T HAVE GOOD
DATA ON THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
APPS AS A WAY TO COLLECT A
REPORT DATA I DON'T HAVE THAT
FOR YOU TODAY [inaudible]
THANK.
IT'S A MEMBER IS.
I I NEED IN REVIEWING THIS
ALREADY I FEEL GOOD ABOUT SOME
OF THIS.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN EMPLOYEES
--
WITH THEIR CORN PLOY THESE I
FEEL VERY GOOD ABOUT THAT.
I FEEL THAT --
THEY KNOW WHAT THE PROCESS IS
AND WHERE WE LOSE THEM IS THE
TRUST IN THE END THEY KNOW THE
PROCESSES THEY KNOW HOW TO
REPORT.
THEY KNOW HOW HOW TO IDENTIFY
HARASSMENT BUT THEY DON'T TRUST
THAT WE AS A LEGISLATURE GOING
TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
IN THE VERY BEGINNING YOU TALKED
ABOUT THIS FAIR AND INCLUSIVE
CLIMATE.
CLEARLY THAT'S WHAT IT IS WE'RE
TRYING TO CHANGE.
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING?
I THINK IT BEGINS WITH.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE OUR
THE POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THAT
YOU HAVE IN PLACE APPROPRIATE.
FOR TODAY'S ENVIRONMENT.
AND HOW EFFECTIVE IS THE
EXECUTION OF THOSE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
RESEARCH.
IN THE INDUSTRY ABOUT TRAINING
AND AND MANY ORGANIZATIONS ARE
DOING TRAINING --
BUT IT'S MORE OF A CHECK THE BOX
TRAINING DID EVERYONE GO THROUGH
THE TRAINING.
VERSES HOW EFFECTIVE WAS THE
TRAINING.
AT EDUCATING THE EMPLOYEES ON
THE PROCESSES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO THEM.
HOW MUCH CONFIDENCE DOES THAT
COHORT HAVE BEEN USING THAT
PROCESS SO --
STEPS TO TAKE AROUND THAT WOULD
BE TO ASK THOSE QUESTIONS AS
PART OF THE TRAINING EVALUATION.
SO IT'S NOT JUST DID YOU ATTEND
BUT ARE YOU NOW COMFORTABLE AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE FOLLOWING THESE
PROCESS THESE.
I ALSO THINK GETTING SUPERVISORY
PERSONNEL TO MODEL.
IF THE INCIDENTS OF HARASSMENT
FOR NOT SUPERVISOR PERSONNEL IS
DOUBLE THAT OF NON SUPERVISORY
PERSONNEL.
WE SHOULD EXPECT THAT WE WOULD
HAVE A LOT OF SUPERVISORY
PERSONNEL USING THAT PROCESS.
AND SO THE EXTENT THAT THAT'S
DONE I THINK THAT WOULD MAKE THE
REST OF THE ORGANIZATION MORE
COMFORTABLE FOLLOWING THE PROPS.
THANK YOU IT AT PAGE TEN
ORGANIZATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
IT'S THOSE EMPLOYEES DO NOT FEEL
SECURE IN THEIR JOBS.
HE PICKED UP OUR I WOULD MY
QUESTION IS IS THERE A QUESTION
BETWEEN FEELING SECURE AND
FEELING.
SAFE.
A FEELING SECURING YOUR JOB OUR
OUR EMPLOYEES ARE AT WILL
EMPLOYEES.
IS THAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THAT THEY DON'T FEEL SECURE
BECAUSE THEY ARE AT WILL
EMPLOYEES.
I THINK IT WAS THE FACT THAT
THEY WEREN'T COMFORTABLE
QUESTIONING A POLICY OR
PROCEDURE WITHOUT FEAR OF BEING
PENALIZED.
THAT WAS THE NATURE OF THAT
ELEMENT.
AND THEN THE LAST AREA IS AT
PAGE [inaudible]
ELEVEN SEE.
THE MOST PREVAILING INDICATION
OF HARASSMENT RESULTED FROM
LOBBYISTS.
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
AS OPPOSED A CONFLUENCE OF
SUPERVISORS WITH AND
LEGISLATORS.
BUT THE DRAFT RECOMMENDATIONS
DON'T ADDRESS.
ANY SPECIFIC REPORTING. FOR THE
ISSUES RELATED TO LOBBYISTS AND
THE THIRD PARTY OR THIRD PARTIES
OR POP UP PUBLIC.
I THINK THAT WOULD GO BACK TO
OUR FIRST SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES IN TERMS OF ARE THEY
APPROPRIATE FOR THE CURRENT
CLIMATE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOUR CURRENT
POLICIES SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED
LOBBYISTS OR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC.
BUT IF THEY DON'T THAT WOULD BE
S. A RECOMMENDATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT.
CONSTITUENCY OR THE ACTS THAT
COHORT IS A SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSED.
BY THE POLICIES AND THEY'RE VERY
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT THEN WITH
THE IF IF THERE IS A HARASSMENT.
BY LOBBYIST ON ONE OF OUR STAFF.
DOES NOT REPORT GO TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL DOESN'T GO
THROUGH OUR PROCESS AND JUST
JUST TO BE CLEAR THAT THEY'RE
JUST ARE THEY JUST OF THE
CULTURE SURVEY THEY HAVE NOT
REVIEWED OUR POLICIES THEY
THEY'RE NOT GIVING IN THEIR NOT
GIVING SUGGESTIONS AS TO OUR
POLICY SO I THINK.
I WOULD RECOMMEND HOLDING THOSE
KINDS OF QUESTIONS UNTIL WE
PRESENT THE POLICIES.
ALRIGHT I JUST THINK THAT THIS
IS A THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
JUST THINK THAT THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT.
OF THE FINDINGS IT IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HARASSMENT OF OUR
STAFF IF WE'RE FINDING THAT THE
THE GREATEST MAJORITY IS COMING
FROM LOBBYIST IN FROM THE
OUTSIDE.
CLEARLY IT'S SOMETHING TO
ADDRESS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I SEVEN TO TAKE JUST A CHAIR'S
PREROGATIVE JUST JUMP IN AND ASK
YOU A FOLLOW UP QUESTION.
WHICH IS THE QUESTION WAS ABOUT
HARASSMENT.
NOT SPECIFIC TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CORRECT CORRECT SO
JUST TO MAKE THE POINT TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE ALL KNOW
THAT.
YOU'RE ANSWERING THE PHONE YOU
CAN FEEL PRETTY HARASSED BY THE
PUBLIC SOMETIMES IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE.
LEGISLATORS DOING THAT THEY'RE
NOT HAPPY ABOUT KEEP THAT IN
MIND IT ALSO IN THE FUTURE IF WE
DO THIS WHEN WE DO THIS AGAIN.
WE PROBABLY SHOULD FIRST OUTING
SEPARATE LOBBYIST FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC FOR THAT VERY REASON
IT'S A DIFFERENT TO DIFFERENT
ANIMAL IN THIS UNIVERSE.
CONTINUE WITH THE PANEL SENATOR
MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
--
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK
ALL THE STAFF.
WHO TOOK THE TIME TO RESPOND AND
THOSE WHO DIDN'T --
I'M GONNA LOOK TO RULES STAFF
FROM BOTH HOUSES IN THE FIRST
ROW JUST TO VERIFY THAT WHAT I'M
A MISSTATEMENT MONTH I'M ABOUT
TO MAKE IS TRUE AND THAT THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS ENGAGED
TO CLIMATE SURVEY FOR STAFF.
AND SO THIS IS THE FIRST TIME.
I HAVE TO SAY I AS THEY'VE IN MY
PRIOR LIFE AND THEN THE PLAY
BEFORE COMING HERE I WAS
SURPRISED AT THE NUMBER.
OF EMPLOYEES AND LEGISLATE TOWER
WOULD NEVER EXPERIENCE A CLIMATE
SURVEY SO THIS IS VERY NEW.
ARM AND ARE WE NOW WITH ALL
THINGS NEW --
GENERALLY REGARDLESS OF THE
CRIME OR CURRENTLY LIVING MAN
THERE WILL BE SKEPTICISM.
IF YOU COULD FLIP TO PAGE TWENTY
TWO FORMALLY.
I DISLIKE TWENTY TWO I
APPRECIATE THAT --
MAYBE IT'S LIKE [inaudible]
TWENTY THREE YES.
BECAUSE GIVEN THE FACT THAT IT'S
NEW WE HAVE A UP BY AN EMPLOYEE
POOL THAT NEVER.
PARTICIPATED IN A CLIMATE SO BE
BEFORE WE PAINSTAKINGLY SENSE
CRAFTED THE LETTERS THAT WERE
SIGNED BY LETTER SHIP LEADERSHIP
AND PAINSTAKINGLY.
LOOK AT THE WORDING OF EVERY
QUESTION TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE ASKING THE RIGHT QUESTIONS
TO GET TO A ROUTE ANSWERED THAT.
ALL WAS USEFUL IN THIS PROCESS.
AND SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE E.
IN PS COLUMN.
WHEN I LOOK AT THE DETRACTOR
PASSIVE PROMOTER NUMBERS?
THAT TO ME LOOKS LIKE AN
ORGANIZATIONAL BELL CURVE.
WHICH CAN BE --
TRANSPOSED TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
WE CERTAINLY ARE ELECTED BY THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE WE
REPRESENT MAY NOT.
THAT CAN BE TRANSPOSON MANY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROBABLY
WOULD BE CONSIDERED HEALTHY.
YOU GOT DISSED DETRACTORS.
THE VAST MAJORITY ON THE PASSIVE
I COME TO WORK EVERYDAY AND DO
MY JOB WHATEVER.
AND THEN THE PROMOTERS WHO ARE
TRUE CHAMPIONS IN CHEERLEADERS
SO THAT'S HOW I PRINT READ THE
THREE FIFTY SIX FIVE FORTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR THAT IT SORT OF EAT
AND THAT'S A BELL CURVE.
LOW HIGH THEN GOES BACK LOW.
SO HELP ME UNDERSTAND.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU SAY THE RAIN
SHOULD BE ONE TO THIRTY AND WE
SEE A NEGATIVE NUMBER UP THERE.
THAT DOESN'T COMPETE WITH MY
INTERPRETATION OF THE BELL
CURVE'S NUMBERS SO HELP ME.
I AGREE WITH YOU IT DOES LOOK
LIKE A BELL CURVE IN TERMS OF
THOSE DATA.
BEING IT E. NPS CALCULATION IS A
DIFFICULT ONE TO STRINGENT ONE
SO THAT MATH IS WE TAKE THE
NUMBER OF PROMOTERS.
WE SUBTRACT THE NUMBER OF
DETRACTORS AND WE DIVIDE BY ALL.
SO IT'S A MEASURE THAT'S VERY
DIFFICULT AND IT'S ONE THAT THE
RESEARCH SHOWS IF WE CAN GET
POSITIVE.
IT BEGETS MORE POSITIVITY WE
HAVE MORE PEOPLE.
BEING CHAMPIONS CHEERLEADERS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE AND IT BECOMES
IN FACT.
SO THAT IT IS YOUR RIGHT IT'S A
BELL CURVE DATA.
BUT WE WOULD.
AND THIS METRIC LIKE TO SEE MORE
OF THOSE PROMOTERS [inaudible]
GOT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THAT HELPS ME.
HE TURNED BACK TO SLIDE THIRTEEN
FORMING IT'S ANOTHER METHODOLOGY
QUESTION THAT I'M JUST NOT
TRACKING.
SO HELP ME AGAIN WHAT THE HELL
E. AYE AND THREE POINT SIX FIVE
ON THE BOTTOM YEAH THAT'S
DIVIDED BY.
CARRIED THE ONE HELP EARLY.
SO WE WE LOOKED AT EACH
RESPONDENTS.
RATINGS OF THESE ITEMS AND THEY
RATED THEM ON A FIVE POINT SCALE
OF AGREEMENT FIVE AS I STRONGLY
AGREE.
IF THE RATING ACROSS ALL FIVE OF
THOSE ITEMS WAS THREE POINT SIX
FIVE OR HIGHER THAT INDIVIDUALS
DEEMED TO BE ENGAGED BY THAT
PARTICULAR DRIVER GOD THEY WOULD
BE IN THE PROMOTER CATEGORY IN
IN THAT VERNACULAR YES GOT IT.
AND SO IT'S A LITTLE MORE
DIFFICULT TO GET SOMEONE TO KEEP
THAT AVERAGE RATING OF THREE DOT
SIX FIVE THAN JUST LOOKING AT
PAUL RADER'S WHO AGREE.
WITH THOSE STATEMENTS QUE.
SO THEN THIS SAYS IN THE FIRST
FLY THE LEGISLATURE CONSISTENTLY
DEMONSTRATES THE DELIVERING HIGH
QUALITY SERVICE TO THE PUBLIC IS
A HIGH PRIORITY. 69% ARE THEY
OUT THE THREE POINT SIX FIVE
PLUS SOME IT WAS 69% RATED THAT
A FOUR OR FIVE I GOT ANGRY OR I
STRONGLY AGREE WITH THAT GUY
[inaudible]
GOD.
AND MY LAST QUESTION MADAM CHAIR
IF I MAY IF THEY GOT A SLY.
TWENTY SIX ALL I APPRECIATE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF AND I'M CLEAR
IN TERMS OF YOUR LANE BUT WHAT
ROLE.
YOU PLAY IN THIS PROCESS AND
WHAT ROLE WE THAT PLAY IN TAKING
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU HAVE
GLEANED FROM LEGISLATIVE STAFF
AND DOING SOMETHING WITH IT.
WHICH IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT I HOPE THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO DO --
AND SO I YOUR QUESTION THREE ARE
YOU STATEMENT REFERRING TO
TRANSPARENCY BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THE STEPS INVOLVED IN THE
PROPHECIES INCLUDING WHO WILL BE
HANDLING COMPLAINTS IN ORDER TO
MITIGATE FEAR OF RETALIATION.
AND I'M JUST NOT SURE THAT.
ONLY CLARITY ABOUT THE NEXT
STEPS ALONE CAN ACTUALLY
MITIGATE FEAR MY SENSE IS.
WHAT DRIVES THE FEE AROUND
RETALIATION?
IS MUCH MORE COMPLICATED THAN ME
JUST UNDERSTAND IN THE PROCESS
AND WHO WILL DO WHAT NEXT.
SO COULD YOU EXPAND ON YOUR
STATEMENT A LITTLE MORE.
YET IN THE DATA WE SAW THERE WAS
A SENSE THAT THERE WOULD BE NO
THERE WAS A THERE WAS A RISK OF
RETALIATION IF I WAS A REPORTER.
OR IF I EXPERIENCED.
SO.
HAVING TRANSPARENCY ABOUT WHAT
EXACTLY IS THE PROCESS WHAT CAN
I EXPECT.
HAS A REPORTER OF EITHER
WITNESSING OR EXPERIENCING
HARASSMENT. TO HEAR BACK FROM
WHOM BY WHEN.
WAS THE NET NATURE OF THE OF THE
DATA THAT WE SAW AROUND THIS I
SO THE ABSENCE OF INFORMATION
CAN THEN KIND OF FUEL THAT SEE I
KNEW I SHOULD THE TOLD THAT.
AS OF THE ABSENCE OF INFORMATION
I GUESS LIKE I GET YOU THEN
FUELS THE FEAR BASED ON THAT
THAT YOU KIND OF HAVE
CONVERSATION ITH YOURSELF YEAH
OKAY AND SO THAT'S WHY I DID IT
IS PROMOTION BECAUSE THAT GOES
BACK TO THAT.
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T HEAR WHAT THE
NEXT STEPS WHERE I FOLLOW YOU.
ALL I REALLY APPRECIATE OUT THE
ENGAGEMENT WITH YOUR FIRM.
I'M I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT --
STEP THAT THE LEGISLATURE TOOK
IN TERMS OF ENGAGING ALL
EMPLOYEES.
AND ENGAGE THEMSELVES TALK WHY
AM I HERE WHAT WILL IT TAKE FOR
ME TO STAY HERE.
I DON'T GET IT IN EMPOWERS US
WITH -- THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE.
TO OUR EMPLOYEE PULL --
TO BOTH MANAGE AND HELP
ESTABLISH EXPECTATIONS --
ALL OF US WANT TO WORK SOMEPLACE
WITH A PAY S. ARE.
PERCEPTION OF OUR OWN VALUE.
EXCEPT EXCEPT ERA --
AND SO TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE WITH
THEIR WORKFORCE REALISTICALLY
ABOUT AREAS WHERE THEY ARE
FINITE RESOURCES BUT AREAS WHERE
WE CAN STRETCH IT'S AN
ORGANIZATION THEY PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING.
I AM SO PROUD TO SEE THE
RESPONSES AROUND COWORKER MUTUAL
RESPECT ENGAGEMENT AND YOUR
EXPERIENCES WITH YOUR IMMEDIATE
SUPERVISOR --
THAT IS.
A VERY TELLING.
AND WE AS A LEGISLATURE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE GIVEN THE FACT QUITE
FRANKLY THAT WE'VE PROVIDED.
LIMITED SUPPORT TO OUR
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS IN
TERMS OF TRAINING AND WHATEVER
THAT THEY HAVE DONE.
AMAZING WORK WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY WERE GIVEN AND SO I
HOPE THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE GAS.
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
SUPPORTS TO CONTINUE --
TO DO BETTER I LIKE THE RESET
RECOMMENDATION AND I THINK THAT
WE'VE GOT.
TO GIVE --
INCLUDED THAT FIGURE OUT A WAY
THAT WE NOT ONLY PROVIDE TREATED
TO EXISTING EMPLOYEES BUT HOW WE
KIND OF STRATEGICALLY APPROACH
HOW WE ON BOARD EMPLOYEES.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S BEEN A
REAL --
FOCUSED AREA FRANKLY OF OUR WORK
BUT HOW WE ONBOARD NEW STAFF.
ON IT IS CLEAR TO ME THAT THIS
IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF THE
WORK -- IT'S
WHAT WE DO WITH THAT AND AND I
KNOW --
THROUGH THIS BY CAMEL PROCESS --
WE'RE NOT GONNA LET IT GO AND
WILL CONTINUE TO UNDO ALL WE CAN
TO IMPROVE THOSE LOWER
PERFORMING NUMBERS AND GETTING
IN TO PROVIDE SUPPORT.
ON THOSE HIGH PERFORMING AREAS
FOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND THAT.
THANK YOU AYE MR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I THINK
YOU'RE VERY TOUCHED ON THIS
PRETTY WELL.
BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR ON PAGE.
ELEVEN YOU DO USE THE TITLE
LOBBYIST SLASH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC.
SINCE YOU PUT LOBBYIST FIRST YOU
KNOW WE JUST.
NATURAL REACT THAT IT MUST BE
THE LOBBYIST --
SO I'M JUST CURIOUS DID YOU
DIFFERENTIATOR SEGREGATE.
OR WAS I JUST ONE CATEGORY
[inaudible]
AND IT WAS ONE CATEGORY JUST
WRITTEN THE WAY YOU SAW.
SO COULD BE 1% LOBBYIST 99%
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WEEK.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW WE DON'T KNOW
SO WE CAN'T JUMP TO CONCLUSIONS
BECAUSE THE FIRST THING WAS ALL
MY GOODNESS WHAT'S WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE SO WE CAN MAKE THAT
CONCLUSION.
WE DO KNOW THAT OUR STAFF GET
PLENTY OF FUN PHONE CALLS FROM
[inaudible]
CONSTITUENTS AND SINCE IT'S
OUTSIDE THE WORKFORCE --
DO YOU ASKED THIS QUESTION
OFTEN.
IN OTHER SURVEYS.
IF THERE'S AN INTERACTION WITH
THE PUBLIC THAT SUBSTANTIAL AS
PART OF A ROLL YES [inaudible]
SO THEN --
THAT JUST.
WHAT JUST DAB?
PART OF THE JOB IS GONNA.
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHY YOU GET
BATTLE PAY OR WHATEVER.
WE CALL IT JUST.
SO WHAT WHY WOULD IT BE ASKED.
USUALLY TO SEE HOW THE
ORGANIZATION IS SET UP TO HANDLE
ISSUES THAT COME FROM THAT
INTERACTION ARE THERE PROCESSES
IN PLACE TO PROTECT EMPLOYEES
[inaudible]
FROM.
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR FROM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IF THAT'S
PART OF THEIR ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND IS IT USUALLY HIGHER THAN
OTHER CATEGORIES IN OTHER
SURVEYS.
TYPICALLY NOT AT THIS LEVEL NOT
NOT THIS HIGH.
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW WE DEVELOP A
POLICY. TO ADDRESS THAT.
I THINK IT'S PART OF THAT
OVERALL POLICY THAT YOU KOW
YOU'RE.
REFLECTING THAT'S AN ELEMENT OF
THEIR ROLES AND IF THERE'S A
PROBLEM FROM THAT ELEMENT HERE'S
WHAT YOU DO ABOUT IT AS AN
EMPLOYEE. TO APPROPRIATE REPORT
APPROPRIATELY REPORT THAT
[inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
IF YOU HAVE CHAIR.
THANK YOU SUMMER DALY. TO FOLLOW
PRO QUIT ON SO WHAT WERE YOU
EARN IT DID YOU HELP PUT THE
SURVEY TOGETHER YES AND SO IN
YOUR EXPERIENCES WOULD IS WAS
IT.
A SO WE GO FORWARD IS THERE IS
THERE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS YOU
HAVE THAT MAYBE WE CAN GET MORE
PARTICIPATION.
SO PARTICIPATION IS DRIVEN BY
COMMUNICATION.
AGAIN TWO ELEMENTS I TALKED
ABOUT ALREADY.
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THESE DATA SO
WELL ONE THING THAT WE SHOULD TO
PUT INTO THE FORMAL
RECOMMENDATIONS IS?
FIRST AND FOREMOST COMMUNICATE
BACK TO ALL STAKEHOLDERS OF
THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING.
WE GOT THE DATA AND WE'LL BE
WORKING ON IT JUST THAT SIMPLE
MESSAGE REINFORCES FOR THEM THAT
YOU TOOK THAT SERIOUSLY AND
SOMETHING WILL HAPPEN.
AND THEN PRIOR TO THE NEXT
SURVEY AS MUCH COMMUNICATION IS
POSSIBLE IN EVERY FORUM THAT YOU
HAVE AVAILABLE SO CERTAINLY THE
LETTERS FROM LEADERSHIP HELP BUT
LITERALLY MY DIRECT SUPERVISOR
SAYING TO ME PLEASE TAKE A
SURVEY.
I'D LIKE TO GET YOUR
PARTICIPATION IS VERY IMPACTFUL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
Q. SENATOR BATES.
I'M LOOKING AT SLIDES AYE
NUMBER.
US SIX REGARDING THE ELIGIBLE
PARTICIPANTS PARTICIPANTS AND
I'M CURIOUS ABOUT THE VOLUNTEERS
SIGN BEING THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT.
COME THROUGH HERE MY ONLY WHERE
TWO OR THREE MONTHS OF WINTERS
HOW DID YOU ARE FACTORED THAT IN
INSURANCE AWAY YOU WAITED THE
RESPONSES I KNOW YOU HAVE ONE TO
THREE YEARS.
ARE IN TERMS OF ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES.
BUT MANY OF OUR PEOPLE IN THERE
THAT WAS HEAVILY SKEWED WITH
VOLUNTEER RESPONSES COULD YOU
PICK THEM ALL UP BY THAT --
THEIR EMAIL THAT COULD HAVE
AFFECTED.
THE TREND I SEE THIS IS A TREND
HERE IN TERMS THE WAY PEOPLE
FEEL ABOUT.
YOU KNOW OUR INSTITUTIONS SO
COULD YOU EXPLAIN.
THE VOLUNTEERS SPONSON IN
WHETHER.
YOU KNOW THERE WAS SOMETHING ON
THE SURVEY WE DID REPUBLICANS
DID NOT HAVE INPUT ON TYPICALLY
SO WE DIDN'T HAVE A WAY. TO TO
MEASURE THAT WHEN WE WERE
REVIEWING THIS BEFORE TODAY'S
MEETING.
SO IN THE FINDINGS THAT WE
PRESENTED WE DIDN'T WAIT AND THE
GROUP OVER ANOTHER SO WAS SUCH
TOTAL.
AVERAGE OF ALL RESPONDENTS.
SO THEY WOULD HAVE HAD TO HAVE
WORKED OR BEEN PRESENT.
IN ON THE LEGISLATURE FOR A YEAR
OR MORE BEFORE YOU ACCEPTED
THAT.
IN THE DATA.
WE WE SENT ONE TO THREE YEARS
THIS YEAR LOSS COUNT.
YET WE RECEIVED A FILE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE WITH EMPLOYEES AND
WHEN WE DID NOT PARKS THAT FILE.
WE'VE WE TOOK THE FILE THAT WAS
PROVIDED AN I DON'T KNOW THE
EXACT CRITERIA AS TO WHO WAS
INCLUDED.
OTHER THAN THE FILE THAT WE
RECEIVED I ONLY MENTION IT
BECAUSE I THINK THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT BEING SO.
SO.
YOU KNOW PREVALENT DURING THE
CLIMATE SURVEY.
AND THE FOLKS THAT WERE
RESPONDING OFF HAD ON FEWER
YEARS HERE THAT RESPONDED OF YOU
KNOW AND MORE NUMBERS STAND
THOSE WHO'VE BEEN HERE A NUMBER
OF YEARS --
MIGHT HAVE SOMETHING TO DO WITH
THAT TOO BECAUSE THERE COULD BE
IMPRESSIONS OUR PERCEPTIONS.
ALL THAT ARE NECESSARILY --
THAT ACCURATE NOT I THINK IT'S A
GREAT SERVICE THINK IT SHOWS
DEFINITELY TRANSCEND IT HELPS
THOSE I THINK AS WE LOOK AT THE
POLICIES THAT ARE IN
DEVELOPMENT.
BUT I JUST WANT TO GET NOW WHEN
YOU LOOK AT 50% OF THE PEOPLE
THAT WORK HERE DID RESPOND.
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
AN INDICATION THAT NEITHER WE
ARE COMMUNICATING WELL OF THE
DIDN'T KNOW THIS WAS GOING ON
AND HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS. TO THE
POLICIES ARE DEVELOPING.
THE OTHER RESPONSE RATE AGAIN IT
46% IS IN THE RANGE OF WHAT WE
WOULD EXPECT WITH A SURVEY OF
THIS NATURE.
SO IT'S ABOUT RANGERS 3250% SO
WE'RE ACTUALLY THE TOP END OF
THAT RANGE TO THINK IS A VERY
HEALTHY SIGN.
AND IF I MIGHT JUST TO GET
CLARITY SENATOR ARE YOU --
ARE YOU.
SAYING THAT YOU BELIEVE THAT WE
HAD MORE OF THE SHORTER TERM
EMPLOYEES RESPONDING THE LONGER
TERM BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THAT
WE KNOW THAT.
I DON'T THINK THAT WE'VE PART
JUST I'M JUST LOOKING AT THE
PERCENTAGES IN TERMS OF THE
CATEGORIES OF THE LENGTH OF TIME
YOU WORKED HERE.
WELL THIS IS INFORMATION THAT MY
STAFF PUT TOGETHER.
AND SO HE'S ON THAT THAT'S NOT A
PROBLEM RHETORIC ON BECAUSE WE
DO WE KNOW THAT. THREE YEARS IS
THE LENGTH OF TIME PEOPLE THERE.
YOU KNOW THINKING THEY'RE GONNA
STAY WHICH IS A GOOD IN
INDICATOR.
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO
WERE TOO MANY THEY MIGHT LIKE IT
BETTER THAN THOSE WHO ARE SAYING
HEY I'M OUT HERE ITSELF SURE I'M
JUST SAYING IN IT YET HELPS US
AS WE DEVELOP.
THE COMMUNICATION TRANSPARENCY
IN PROTECTION ISSUES THAT WE
WANT TO BRING FORWARD.
IN OUR POLICIES [inaudible]
OKAY --
OTHER TO MS REYES UNLESS YOU
MISS MITCHELL HAD SOMETHING FOR
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS.
OKAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
THANK YOU I WANT TO GO BACK TO
SLIDE. ELEVEN THE MOST BUT SEE
THE MOST VIOLENT INDICATION OF
HARASSMENT RESULTED FROM
LOBBYIST MEMBERS OF PUBLIC.
DO WE KNOW IF THIS WAS
HARASSMENT.
IN THE CAPITAL OUTSIDE DURING
FUNDRAISERS DURING OTHER EVENTS.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT WAS SPECIFICS
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE IS A
HIGHER INCIDENCE OF EMPLOYEES AT
THE CAPITOL.
OF WITNESSED FOR EXPERIENCED
HARASSMENT THAN IN THE
DISTRICTS.
FROM LOBBYISTS OUTSIDE
[inaudible]
OKAY YES.
AND THE OTHER AT ALL YOUR SLIDE.
TWENTY SIX ON EDUCATING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
MY IMPRESSION WAS THAT.
IT WAS THE BYSTANDER TRAINING.
IS THAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
OF MAKING SURE THAT.
DIDN'T THE BYSTANDERS WHO SEE
WHO WITNESSED THIS ARE --
ARE TRAINED SO THAT THEY WILL
REPORT IT YES OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK ON MEDICARE
[inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
YEAH THANK YOU ARM.
I JUST WANTED.
TO I GUESS JUST SAY FOR MYSELF
I'M SORRY MISTER DALI LEFT THAT
--
WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
RECOGNIZE THIS IS ONE DATA POINT
--
THEN I DON'T.
I DON'T CHOOSE --
TO NAY GATE THE DATA PROVIDED TO
US BY THE PERCENTAGE OF THE
EMPLOYEES WHO DID BASED ON AN
OVERWHELMING CONCERN OVER PEOPLE
WHO CHOSE NOT TO PARTICIPATE.
I THINK WE INDIVIDUALLY AS
MEMBERS TO HAVE HAD IT WILL
CONTINUE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO TALK TO OUR STAFF AND OUR OWN
STAFF MEETING.
ABOUT OUR PERCEPTION OF THE
VALUE OF THEIR INPUT --
AND SO I DON'T WANT US TO GET
STUCK IN CONTINUE TO QUESTION
WILL THE FIVE MORE PEOPLE THAT
PARTICIPATED WITH ITS SKILLET.
IT'S JUST ONE DATA POINT THAT
WHAT WHAT WE LEARN HERE.
WILL NOT OVERWHELMINGLY CHANGE
YOUR LIFE EXPERIENCE AS AN
EMPLOYEE HERE IT'S A DATA POINT
IT'S A POINT IN TIME
MEASUREMENT.
OF MY EXPERIENCE EITHER AS A
TWENTY YEAR EMPLOYEE A THREE
YEAR EMPLOYEE --
IT'S GOOD DATA THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO HEAR OR SEE.
IT IS A BENCHMARK FROM WHICH WE
HOPE TO HAVE BONTA GOING
EXPERIENCES RECEIVING DATA --
IT IS MY ASSUMPTION PLEASE
CORRECT ME IF I'M OFF MARK THAT
AS WE MAKE CLIMATE SURVEYS A
PART OF OUR CULTURE AND PEOPLE
COME TO EXPECT AND UNDERSTAND
THE TOOL.
THAT YOUR UP TO CAN
PARTICIPATION INCREASES OVER
TIME IT DOES IF IF THEY SEE
THOSE RESULTS.
TALKED ABOUT CAN THEY SEE ACTION
TAKEN IF WE PRACTICE WHAT WE
PREACH SO AGAIN IF CALL COMES
BACK ON ON US --
THE THIS MAY BE AN UNFAIR
EXPECTED PERCENTAGE OF UPTICK AS
YOU CONTINUE TO HAVE.
SIR BASS I DON'T WORKPLACE YEAH
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A FLAT
OUTCOME IS THAT WE CAN EXPECT
EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THAT IS NO MORE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I WANT TO
THANK TALENT KEEPERS I WANT TO
THANK ESPECIALLY SENATOR
MITCHELL WHO HAD SUGGESTED DOING
THE CLIMATE SURVEY --
IT'S VERY HELPFUL AT ALL ALDOUS
TELL YOU TWO DATA POINTS THAT I
HEARD TODAY THAT I KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO BE
MINDFUL OF IS WE CREATE THE NEW
HARASSMENT THAT WE'RE HEARING
REPORTED FROM LOBBYISTS MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A WAY. FOR THOSE
INCIDENTS TO BE REPORTED AND TO
BE ACTED ON IN SOME WAY COURSES
LIMITATIONS AS TO WHAT WE CAN DO
BUT WE CAN ALSO DO THINGS.
IN TERMS OF KEEPING HARASSING.
THEM A LOBBYIST OR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC --
AWAY FROM OUR STAFF IF THEY
REALLY HAVE ARE CROSSING THE
LINE AND ALSO GIVING STAFF THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED TO KNOW
HOW TO HANDLE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IF THEY'RE FEELING
HARASSED.
BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY DO NOT WANT
OUR STAFF OUTFIELDER ANSWERING
PHONES AND FEELING EVERY DAY
LIKE THEY DON'T COME TO WORK
BECAUSE OF THE LEVEL OF ABUSE
THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING --
AND THE SECOND IS BUILDING ON
THE VERY STRONG RESULT WE SAW
ABOUT THE TRUST OF AND
APPRECIATION OF CO WORKERS.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT TRAINING WE
TALKED ABOUT BYSTANDER TRAINING
AND AND CERTAINLY THIS MAKES
THAT.
ALL THE MORE --
POSITIVE BECAUSE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN REALLY
BUILD ON AS A STRENGTH. TO
HARNESS THAT --
TO THAT KIND OF CULTURE CHANGE
WE WANT.
AND WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT TOPIC THANK
YOU.
AND WE DO HAVE A VERY VERY
SHORT.
POWER POINT BUT MOSTLY WE'RE
GOING TO BE JUSTICE SCOTT
SAYING.
THE POLICIES SO THIS THIS IS NOW
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM SENATOR
MITCHELL REPRESENTING THE SIDE
INTO MYSELF --
A TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON CHANGES
FOR OUR POLICY.
MY GOODNESS NOW I HAVE TO KNOW
HOW TO OPERATE THIS THING THAT I
WAS JUST HANDED.
YEAH. OH ABSOLUTELY I'M SORRY
YES OKAY SENATOR.
THANK YOU I JUST SOME. ONE TO
SAY THAT THIS HAS BEEN IMPORTANT
WORK AND I WANT TO THANK OF THE
ARE CHAIR ONE MEANT FOR THE OUR
SHE'S DEVOTED TO THAT ALL OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT AND YOUR INTEREST --
I SAW COMMERCIAL A LAST NIGHT --
ON TV I THINK IT WAS OUT THE AD
AND THE TAGLINE WAS PROGRESS IS
NEVER STANDING STILL.
ON THAT I THINK OUR ON GOING
WORK IN THIS AREA ON BEHALF OF
THE LEGISLATURE.
ON OUR ENTIRE LEGISLATIVE
COMMUNITY ON THIS REFLECTIVE IN
THAT.
THIS IS NOT AT LEGISLATIVE OR
OVERSIGHT PROCESS A WE ENGAGED
MONTHS AGO NOW AND SAY THE
POLICY FRAMEWORK TO GUIDE THE
LEGISLATURE'S NEXT STEPS IN
REFRAMING OUR INSTITUTIONAL.
CULTURE BASED ON VALUES.
AND WE HAVE BEEN INTENTIONALLY
DELIBERATE TO HAVE --
BECAUSE WE'RE CLEAR THAT WE
CANNOT MICROMANAGE --
OUR GOAL IN OUR ROLE AS
LEGISLATORS IS TO ESTABLISH
POLICY AND OUR INTENT.
GIVEN THAT IMPORTANT ROLE WE
PLAY AS BOTH EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES OF THE PUBLIC THAT HAS
GUIDED OUR APPROACH SHOULD BE
INTENTIONALLY DELIBERATIVE.
WE APPROACH THIS FROM A BALANCED
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE THE REALITY
IS WE'RE DEVELOPING THIS
FRAMEWORK.
IN THE MIDST OF CLAIMS FIELD BY
PUBLIC INTERESTS.
SCRUTINY AND FEAR.
FEAR FROM FELL LEGISLATORS HERE
FROM STAFF --
FEAR FROM EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS.
SO THAT WAS REALLY THE FRAMEWORK
FROM WHICH I APPROACH THIS WORK
AND WE WORKED COLLABORATIVELY --
INTO BY CAMEL WAY THAT TOO CAN
BE A CHALLENGE BECAUSE IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE PRACTICED REGULARLY
IN THIS PLACE WE AB ASSEMBLY OF
THE SENATE WE DO OUR SEPARATE
BUSINESS.
AND SO TO TO PRACTICE A
BICAMERAL STRATEGY IN DEVELOPING
THIS APPROACH WAS EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE ON
IN TERMS OF SHOWING THE EXAMPLE
TO THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY ABOUT
HEY.
HEY HOW IMPORTANT ISSUE WAS.
AND BE HOW CRITICAL IT WAS WE
CAME TOGETHER AS ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS IT --
AND SO I'M PROUD OF THE WORK --
THAT WE'VE PUT INTO IT BOTH THE
PROCESS AND THE OUTCOME.
WE ARE FAR FROM FINISHED OUR AND
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
EVOLVE FOR IT IT --
MYSTERY BUT AND I TO LEAD YOU IN
THIS EFFORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH POT I WANT
TO THANK THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK.
AS YOU CAN SEE.
ALL I PUSHED A BUTTON AND
NOTHING HAPPENED YEAH SO I WAS
JUST.
OKAY THANK YOU WE HAD FIVE
HEARINGS.
BETWEEN JANUARY AND MARCH THAT
DEALT IN TO ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
ASPECTS THAT SHAPE A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT HEARING I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
NOW AS I GO THROUGH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS I'M GOING TO ASK
YOU ALL TO HOLD YOUR QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS UNTIL THE END
EXCEPT FOR SENATOR MITCHELL
BECAUSE WE DID DEVELOP THIS
TOGETHER AS PARTNERS.
AND I WANT HER TO JUMP IN TALK
WITH ME TALK OVER ME --
WE'RE GOING TO BE PRESENTING
THIS TOGETHER AS WE GO THROUGH
--
IT'S GOING TO BE MOSTLY A VERBAL
PRESENTATION --
A THIS IS A OUR FIRST ADDITIONS
TO GIVE YOU THE BROAD POLICY
DIRECTION WE'RE GOING TO BE
FILLING IN A LOT OF BLANKS
OVERTIME WE ALSO WANT TO HEAR
YOUR COMMENTS --
SO THAT NET BETWEEN NOW AND
THURSDAY WE CAN CUT YOU KNOW
EVALUATE THEM AND COME BACK WITH
PERHAPS --
MODIFIED RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
THAT WILL GO TO JOINT RULES FOR
ADOPTION.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH STAFF TO FLESH OUT
ALL OF THE DETAILS AYE BUT THESE
ARE THIS IS THE FRAMEWORK NOT A
COMPLETE SET OF POLICIES
[inaudible]
OKAY SO.
THE ENTIRE PROPOSALS CENTERS ON
CULTURE CHANGE WE HEARD OVER AND
OVER AGAIN FROM ALL OF THE
EXPERTS THAT YOU CAN HAVE A
GREAT WRITTEN POLICY BUT IF YOU
DON'T EMBODIED IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION.
IT DOESN'T REALLY WORK ND SO
CHANGING THE CULTURE IS IS IS
OUR GOAL AND BECAUSE AND BASED
ON THAT EVERY ASPECT OF POLICY
THAT WE HAVE THAT GOES INTO.
SEXUAL AND OTHER TYPES OF
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION WILL CHANGE AND
EVERY CHANGE IS DONE WITH AN EYE
TOWARDS [inaudible]
CULTURE CHANGE.
AND OF AND THAT IS OF A CULTURE
OF RESPECTABILITY IN DIVERSITY
AND I WILL POINT OUT THAT THIS
THIS ISSUE OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT.
WE SEE THIS TO THIS DISCUSSION
GOING ON ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE COMING
FORWARD AND YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE
BEING BRAVE ENOUGH TO COME
FORWARD AND RISK WHATEVER
RETALIATION THEY MIGHT.
HAVE AND WE HAVE TO THANK THEM
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD WITH
THIS THAT'S NOT UNIQUE TO OUR
CULTURE.
BUT WHAT IS A LITTLE BIT UNIQUE
TO OUR CULTURE AND TO MANY OTHER
CULTURES WILL WE SEE A LOT OF US
OF HARASSMENT.
IS A VERY LARGE IMBALANCE
BETWEEN POWER.
OF SOME MEMBERS OF OUR WORK
FORCE AND OTHERS OF COURSE WITH
MEMBERS AND SENIOR STAFF AT THE
TOP OF THAT HIERARCHY.
INTERNS AND YEAH I'M --
ENTRY LEVEL STUFF POSSIBLY BEING
SEEN AS BEING ON THE BOTTOM.
AND THAT AS WE HEARD FROM MANY
EXPERTS IS WHERE YOU YOU KNOW
TEND TO RUN INTO A LOT OF
TROUBLE SO HOW DO WE REALIZING
THAT THAT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE
NECESSARILY DEVELOP THAT CULTURE
OF RESPECTABILITY IN DIVERSITY.
SO THAT EVERYBODY IS VALUED
EVERYBODY TOLERATE HARASSMENT
TOWARDS ANYBODY AND WE HAVE A
WAY OF HAVING A AN ABILITY.
SO EXPANDING REPORTING AN
INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT ADDRESSING
PROBLEMS EARLY IS GOING TO BE A
BIG PART OF THE SOLUTION.
I'M ALSO GOING TO BE SUED
RECOMMENDING THAT WE CREATE FOR
THE FIRST TIME AN INDEPENDENT
BICAMERAL UNIT.
WITH AN INDEPENDENT PANEL OF
EXPERTS TO MAKE FACTUAL FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS SO MOVING ON
A DRILLING DOWN MORE
SPECIFICALLY INTO EACH OF THOSE
AREAS.
I'M THE FIRST AREA IS TO
TRANSFORM THE LEGISLATORS
WORKPLACE CULTURE TO PROMOTE
RESPECT CIVILITY IN DIVERSITY.
AND EVERY PERSON'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO BUILD ON THAT
CULTURE.
WE'RE GOING TO BE ADOPTING A
MORE FORMAL.
POLICY ON A WORKPLACE --
ON WORKPLACE CONDUCT --
WHICH WILL.
TALK ABOUT INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT
TOWARDS OTHERS BASED ON
PROTECTED CLASS SO IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THERE CAN'T BE OTHER
KINDS OF HARASSMENT THAT WOULD
GO THROUGH THE TRADITIONAL HR
PROCESS AS IT DOES NOW.
THIS PANEL WILL DEAL WITH
INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT TOWARDS
OTHERS.
BASED ON PROTECTED CLASS
[inaudible]
AGE [inaudible]
RACE GENDER.
I AM DISABILITY AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION WHAT ARE ALL THE
THINGS THAT THAT POLICY --
BASED ON THIS POLICY APPLIES TO
MEMBERS EMPLOYEES INTERNS BALL
CAGE A* VOLUNTEERS IN
APPLICANTS AND POSSIBLY ALSO TWO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN AND TO
LOBBYISTS.
AS WE HEARD FROM OUR SURVEY.
I'M THE FIRST STEP IS TO CREATE
AN ENGAGING TRAINING PROGRAM WE
HEARD OVER AND OVER THAT EVEN
THOUGH WE'VE HAD A TRAINING
PROGRAM THAT CERTAINLY COMPLY
COMPLIES WITH WHAT'S DONE AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND IS VERY TYPICAL
IN SOME WAYS GOES BEYOND.
WHAT WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS DO?
WE WANT A TRAINING POLICY THAT
IS MUCH MORE ENGAGING.
MUCH MORE INTERACTIVE --
POSSIBLY INVOLVING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ALL OF THAT WILL BE
EXPLORED BUT THE DIRECTION TO
STOCK WILL BE. TO CREATE
SOMETHING THAT'S A LOT MORE
GEARED TOWARDS OUR UNIQUE FOR
PLACE THE TYPES OF INTERACTIONS
THAT WE HAVE THE INCLUDING
SOCIAL EVENTS.
DISTRICT --
AND A WAY THAT THE DISTRICT WORK
SIX SUCH A SODA EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS.
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES AND THEIR
EXPECTATIONS IN THE BUILDING BUT
ALSO OUT IN THE FIELD.
I ALSO JUST ADD AGAIN THAT WE
CAN BUILD ON WHAT WE HEARD ABOUT
THE TRUST AND CO WORKERS WITH
BYSTANDER TRAINING AND OTHER
SORTS OF TRAINING WORK
EMPLOYEES.
RELY ON EACH OTHER.
I'M WE WILL ALSO FIND WAYS TO
PROMOTE RESPECT AND CIVILITY IN
THE LEGISLATIVE WORKPLACE --
SO THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT GOOD
BEHAVIOR AND FIND WAYS TO REWARD
IT.
WE WILL PROTECT EMPLOYEES
[inaudible]
WHO REPORT INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
STRONG ANTI RETALIATION
PROCEDURES AND THAT IF?
PEOPLE DO FEEL THAT THEY'VE BEEN
RETALIATED AGAINST MAKING GO TO
THE PANEL WHO UNDERSTANDS THE
CASE YOU KNOW IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
AND REPORT THAT RETALIATION AND
AND HAVE A PATH TO JUSTICE SO
THAT WE WILL MAKE IT CLEAR THAT.
IN EVERY WAY RETALIATION WILL
NOT BE TOLERATED.
THEN IT MOVING ONTO ADDRESSING
PROBLEMS EARLY AND I THINK THAT
THIS IS KEY IN THIS IS A BIG
CHANGE FROM WHAT HAPPENS NOW.
WE WOULD LIKE [inaudible] TO
MAKE SURE THAT EMPLOYEES
UNDERSTAND THAT WE WOULD LIKE
INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT REPORTED.
EVEN IF IT'S A FIRST TIME
OFFENSE EVEN IF IT'S ONE
COMMENT.
ONE IMAGE ONE JOKE AND THE
REASON IS NOT TO BE PUNITIVE TO
EMPLOYEES OR PUNISH EMPLOYEES IS
TO INTERVENE EARLY TO OFFER
COUNSELING AND OFFER TRAINING
BECAUSE ONE COMMENT MIGHT NOT.
MEAN VERY MUCH OR SEEN
SIGNIFICANT.
BUT IF IF THAT BEHAVIOR
CONTINUES AND NOW YOU HAVE TEN
TWENTY THIRTY OF THOSE SAME
KINDS OF INCIDENCES NOT ONLY DO
WE HAVE ARE PERHAPS I'LL A
WORKPLACE THAT DOES HAVE
HARASSMENT.
BUT NOW THAT EMPLOYEE HAS
POSSIBLY CROSSED A LINE TO THE
LEGAL DEFINITION OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WORDS IF WE'D
INTERVENE EARLY WE COULD HAVE
CORRECTED THAT PATH.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THAT PERSON
I'M UNDERSTOOD THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THEIR BEHAVIOR.
I IN A WAY THAT.
IS PROTECTIVE OF THAT PERSON AS
WELL AS THE PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE
INTERACTING WITH SO WE CAN.
INTERVENE EARLY COUNSEL EARLY WE
CAN PROTECT PEOPLE'S JOBS AND
HAVE A BETTER WORK ENVIRONMENT
AND MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS WHAT WE EXPECT IN
TERMS OF CONDUCT TOWARDS OTHERS.
SO WITH THAT GOAL WE WILL CREATE
A WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT THAT'S
THE UNIT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THAT'S A BICAMERAL UNIT WERE
REPORTS OF THAT NATURE CAN.
GO I WILL ALSO HAVE TO TRAIN OUR
EMPLOYEES THAT WE EXPECT AND WE
WANT THEM TO REPORT.
THOSE INFRACTIONS THOSE
VIOLATIONS OF WORKPLACE CONDUCT
SO IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO BE HELD AGAINST YOU WE
WANT TO INCREASE THE REPORTING
OF THOSE VIOLATIONS THAT WE
CAN'T INTERVENE EARLY AND THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE TRAINING OF OUR
WORKPLACE.
SORRY WE TRYING.
TO GET THAT WORD IN EDGEWISE.
OKAY I'M SORRY --
THIS YEAR YES THAT'S THAT SECOND
PART SUPERVISORS AND OTHERS WILL
BE ENCOURAGED TO REPORT THAT
WILL BE WHAT WE EXPECT THEM TO
DO.
AND I BELIEVE THAT ONCE THAT
UNDERSTANDING IS OUT THERE THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE
RETALIATION AND FACT WE WANT YOU
KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE ENCOURAGING
THAT REPORTING.
WE ARE GOING TO OFFER
COMPLETENESS ALTERNATIVES FOR
ADDRESSING PROBLEMS SO WE'RE
GOING TO HOPE TO INCORPORATE.
THE SORT OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
TECHNIQUES AND OTHER PATHS THAT
WE SEE AS LONG AS PEOPLE ARE
WILLING --
AT MEDIATION EARLY NOW NOT
MEDIATION WITH THE PERSON WHO
HAD THE VIOLATION BUT POSSIBLY
MEDIATION WITH UMMAH THE
SUPERVISORS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A WORKPLACE THAT WE THAT IS
RESPECTFUL OF EVERYBODY.
SO WHEN COMPLAINTS COME IN JUST
TO EXPLAIN HOW THIS WILL WORK
EVERY COMPLAINT WILL BE TRIAGE
IMMEDIATELY SO THAT IF WE NEED
IMMEDIATE ACTION THAT CAN BE
TAKEN IF WE NEED NEED TO
INTERVENE RIGHT AWAY TO PREVENT
A SITUATION FROM ESCALATING THAT
WILL HAPPEN.
IF IT'S JUST COUNSELING OR
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE QUICKLY
ADJUDICATED THAT WILL HAPPEN --
SO THE MORE SERIOUS VIOLATIONS
OF COURSE WILL SORT OF MOVE UP
ON THAT SCALE AND OTHER THINGS
YOU KNOW MAYBE CAN WAIT A LITTLE
WHILE SO BUT THERE WILL BE
IMMEDIATE.
EVALUATION OF EVERY COMPLAINT
THAT'S THAT IS RECEIVED
[inaudible]
I'M.
AT IF APPROPRIATE WILL ENGAGE
THE ENTIRE OFFICE TEAM TO USE
THAT AS A LEARNING PROCESS NOW
MOVING ON TO INVESTIGATE REPORTS
PROMPTLY.
WE WILL BE CREATING A PANEL OF
FIVE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS AND
TO BE CLEAR THIS IS NOT.
AN AVERAGESORT OF CITIZENS
PANEL THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
THIRTY TWENTY FORTY YEARS OF
EXPERTISE AS EMPLOYMENT
ATTORNEYS.
OF AS JUDGES WHO HAVE HANDLED
THESE KINDS OF CASES WHO PEOPLE
WHO NOT ONLY UNDERSTAND THE LAW
BUT WILL COME TO UNDERSTAND OUR
POLICIES SO THAT THEY CAN LOOK
AT EVERY CASE IN AN
INDIVIDUALIZED WAY. TO EXPLORE
THE NUANCES OF EVERY CASE SO
THAT THEY SO THAT RESPONSES WILL
BE TAILORED TO THE INDIVIDUALS
WITH AN EYE TOWARDS CULTURE
CHANGE AND TRAINING AND
CORRECTIVE PATHS.
I WANT APPROPRIATE OF COURSE OF
DISCIPLINE THAT'S APPROPRIATE TO
THAT TO THAT PARTICULAR INCIDENT
--
WEATHER REPORT COMES IN IT WILL
BE CLASSIFIED FOR FURTHER ACTION
AND THAT IF WE NEED TO THERE
WILL BE MORE THEY'LL BE EVIDENCE
GATHERING WE WILL HAVE IN HOUSE
INVESTIGATORS.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
AN EMPLOYEE WORKFORCE THAT TRUST
US TO CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS.
NOW IF THERE ARE MEMBERS
INVOLVED OR STAFF THAT ARE
CONSIDERED TO BE ABOVE THE LEVEL
OF THOSE INVESTIGATORS THAT'S WE
WILL CONSIDER SENDING OUT TO
OUTSIDE INVESTIGATORS THAT
THERE'S NO QUESTION.
OF FAIRNESS --
AS THOSE REPORTS ARE DONE.
OR AS YOU KNOW OF BIAS AND ARE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS WILL
REVIEW [inaudible]
THE EVIDENCE THEY WILL DISCUSS
THE INCIDENT AMONGST THEMSELVES
THEY WILL THEN CONVENE THEIR
PANEL AND SPEAK TO THE
SUPERVISOR COMPANY WHO HAS
KNOWLEDGE TO SAY TO THEM.
THIS IS OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT HAPPENED IS THIS YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT HAPPENED
AND THEY WILL DISCUSS THAT AND
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY THAT THAT
THE PANEL TRULY UNDERSTANDS WHAT
THE INCIDENT WAS.
WHAT THE BACKGROUND IS WHAT LED
UP TO IT ALL OF THE RELEVANT
FACTORS AND THEN BASED ON THAT
THEY WILL MAKE A RECOMMENDATION?
TO THE SUPERVISORS --
I HAVEN'T TO THE HOUSE OR TO THE
IMMEDIATE SUPERVISOR OF THAT
HOUSE.
THE HOUSE WILL EACH INDIVIDUAL
HOUSE WILL THEN HAVE THE ABILITY
TO RESPOND AS THEY SEE FIT BASED
ON THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS.
BUT THERE WILL BE WRITTEN
RECOMMENDATIONS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM EXPERTS YOU
KNOW GIVEN --
YOU KNOW WITH THEIR BACKGROUND
IN LAW AND IN OUR POLICIES
[inaudible]
THEN.
YEAH EACH HOUSE WILL THEN HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO DETERMINE THE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE.
THE CURRENT POLICY RELATED TO
DISCLOSURE RELATING TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WILL BE MAINTAINED
WHICH IS SERIOUS.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST SENIOR STAFF AND MEMBERS
WILL CONTINUE TO BE RELEASED --
BUT AS WE ARE ALSO TRYING TO
PARSE OUT NOW REPORTING AT A
MUCH EARLIER PHASE OF THINGS
THAT FALL BELOW THE LEVEL OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OTHER TYPES OF
WORST PLACE RUMINATION.
THAT AS AND WITH ALL OF OUR
EMPLOYEES MATTERS WILL BE KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL BECAUSE WE'RE
DEALING WITH EMPLOYEES AND
THOSE.
ARC CONSIDER CHIN NOT RISE TO
THAT LEVEL.
OF OF BEING SERIOUS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
THAT IS THE BASIC FRAMEWORK OF
THE POLICY WITH OF COURSE SOME
DETAILS TO BE FILLED IN BUT IT'S
VERY MUCH A SEA CHANGE FROM
WHAT'S DONE NOW. FOR ONE THING
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A BICAMERAL
UNIT WHICH IS NOT CURRENTLY
DONE.
THAT BI CAMERAL UNIT WILL ASK
FOR FOR WE WILL ASK OUR
EMPLOYEES TO REPORT ON A MUCH
BROADER RANGE OF INCIDENTS THAN
WE EVER HAVE IN THE PAST.
AND WE WILL ALSO HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT PANEL FOR THE FIRST
TIME OF SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
WHO WILL INVESTIGATE WILL LOOK
INTO EVERYONE OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS BASED ON ALL
INFORMATION THAT'S PROVIDED FROM
INVESTIGATORS.
FROM THEM THE I EMPLOYEES
THEMSELVES WHO WILL DISCUSS EACH
INCIDENT AND RECOMMEND THE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE BASED ON
THEIR YEARS OF WORK IN THIS
FIELD --
THAT'S THE BASIC FRAMEWORK ALL
LAST SENATOR MITCHELL OF SHE HAS
ANYTHING TO ADD.
TRYING TO DISTILL WAS A VERY
LARGE POLICY DOWN INTO A KIND OF
BITE SIZE PIECES BUT THIS IS A
VERY BIG CHANGE FROM WHAT WE
HAVE DONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE ONLY
THING I WOULD ADD I REALLY IN
SUMMARY IS RECOGNIZING.
I THINK THE TWO PRIMARY
TAKEAWAYS --
AND THE GOAL IS BOTH THE
INTEGRITY AND CONSISTENCY OF THE
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS THE FACT
FINDING PROCESS.
AND THE INTEGRITY AND
CONSISTENCY OF THE RULE MAKING
PROCESS IF YOU WILL OF OF WHAT.
WAS ULTIMATELY DONE WITH THE
INVESTIGATORS NO FACTUAL
FINDINGS.
AND CREATING THIS UNIT.
THAT -- WILL
ENGAGE IN THAT WORK ON BEHALF OF
BOTH HOUSES.
AND DEVELOPING THIS PANEL
CREATES -- I
FEEL AN APPROPRIATE BALANCE
BETWEEN WHAT ROLE WE PLAY AS A
LEGISLATURE.
BOMB AND CREATING THIS
OPPORTUNITY FOR AN INDEPENDENT
ENTITY TO HELP INFORM OUR
DECISIONS AGAIN --
TO MAINTAIN INTEGRITY AND
CONSISTENCY ON BOTH THE
INVESTIGATION SIDE AS WELL AS
THE RULE MAKING I THINK FOR ME.
TO CONCEPTUALLY WALK AWAY WITH
TWO NEW CONCEPTS THAT'S THE WAY
I WOULD FRAME IT --
AND AGAIN THAT.
BY THE SLY MEMBER STOP WITH THE
HEARINGS THAT WE ALL
PARTICIPATED IN.
KEY SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS THAT
WE ALL HEARD FROM.
AND TAKING ALL THAT INFORMATION
AND DISTILLING THAT WITHIN OUR
OWN UNIQUE STRUCTURAL FRAMEWORK
HERE WE FELT OF IT REALLY WAS
THE BEST PLAN TO ALLOW US. TO GO
FORWARD --
RECOGNIZING OUR ROLE AS
EMPLOYERS AND ALL OF US AND
EMPLOYEES AS WELL.
IT IMPACTS ALL OF US UNDER THE
DOME.
YEAH AND ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND IT ALSO BEARS --
POINTING OUT THAT THIS PROCESS
IS THE SAME FOR MEMBERS AND FOR
EMPLOYEES IT WILL BE THE SAME
PROCESS WILL BE ASKING FOR THE
SAKE REPORTING OF THE SAME TYPES
OF INCIDENTS.
WE ARE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
PROCESS THAT WE ARE ASKING OUR
EMPLOYEES TO BE SUBJECTED TO BE
SUBJECTED.
TO AND THAT'S IMPORTANT --
WE EXPECT THE SAME IF NOT BETTER
BEHAVIOR HERE FROM LEGISLATORS
AND WE SHOULD.
AS YOUR EMPLOYEES AND THE PANEL
WHEN THEY WE HEAR EVIDENCE WILL
BE TREATING US IN MAKING THE
SAME RECOMMENDATIONS AS THEY
WOULD FOR EMPLOYEES BECAUSE
THEY'RE MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS
BASED ON WHAT OUR POLICY IS AND
WHAT THE LAW IS.
AND WITH THAT I WILL TURN TO THE
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
COMMENTS ARE SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'D FIRST
WANT THINK MADAM CHAIR MADAM
VICE CHAIR THIS WAS A LOT OF
WORK AND TO ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
AND BUT HOW CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
IT IS AND I THINK HOW BEING.
POLICIES IN PLACE SINCE I WAS
ELECTED FOUR YEARS AGO SOMETHING
HAS ALWAYS STRUCK ME IS THAT.
WERE LIKE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
LITTLE SMALL BUSINESSES AND SO
MANY OUT FOLKS WERE ELECTED
NEVER HAD A STAFF BEFORE AND SO
THEY'RE PRACTICING IF YOU WILL
WITH THEIR STAFF THAT THEY HAVE
HERE.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE EVER STARTS
OUT WITH BAD INTENTIONS BUT
PEOPLE JUST DON'T KNOW SO I
THINK HAVING A FRAMEWORK AND
HAVING IT BE BY CAMEL THAT WAS
SOMETHING ELSE THAT STRUCK ME
WAS WHEN I WAS ELECTED.
HOW WE DO THINGS SO SEPARATELY
EVEN THE WORD ENDEAVORING TO
CREATE LAWS FOR THE ENTIRE STATE
TOGETHER SO I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE
DOING THIS AS A BY CAMEL UNIT?
AND AND I THINK THE FUTURE IS
BRIGHT I THINK THAT THE THAT
RESULTS FROM THE SURVEY WERE
CERTAINLY NOT --
AS BAD AS I THOUGHT THEY MIGHT
[inaudible] TO DO AND I ALSO TO
TOUCH ON WHAT SENATOR MITCHELL
SAID I THINK THAT --
WE ALWAYS WANT MORE PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE BUT THAT IS OUR
CHALLENGE FOR EVER WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE APATHY IN SOCIETY PEOPLE
DON'T WANT VOTE SO GETTING
SOMEONE TO FILL OUT A SURVEY
ISN'T ALWAYS GOING TO BE EASY
BUT WE WILL ENDEAVOR TO KEEP
MOVING FORWARD.
AND I JUST WANT PEOPLE THROUGH
AGAIN AND EVERYONE THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT AND
VITAL WORK AND I THINK THESE ARE
REAL STEPS THAT ARE GONNA MOVE
US FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER DALY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THEN
VICE CHAIR I JUST ONE OF THE
FIRST FALL.
TAKE EVERY MEMBER ON THIS PANEL
FOR TAKING THE TIME AND NO I
DON'T BELIEVE ANYBODY MISS ANY
TIME AND THAT'S RARE AROUND
HERE.
SO I WANT TO SAY THAT I'M.
EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT WHAT'S THE
PROCESS FROM HERE FORWARD NOW
I'M THIS LOOKING AT WHAT.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE SO HOW
HOW DO SO I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
AS I HAVE BEEN ALL ALONG THAT.
WE NEED A GREAT OF I HEARD WE
HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT CULTURE
WHICH WE ALL AGREED WE NEED.
TO HAVE THAT CULTURE CHANGED
HERE WE ALSO --
HEARD A LOT ABOUT TRUST AT THE
END OF THE DAY.
WE REALLY HAVE TO HAVE A PROCESS
THAT'S IN PLACE THAT TOM
[inaudible]
OUR EMPLOYEES.
AND US AS WELL HAVE A PLACE TO
GO -- THAT
WE CAN TRUST THE PROCESS AND SO
--
WHEN THERE WHEN I SEE THAT THAT
THAT RETAIN THEIR WHAT THE THE
ONE WHICH HAS RETAIN HOUSE
AUTHORITY TO DETERMINE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE SO I WOULD
LIKE SOME CLARIFICATION ON WHAT
THAT MEANS --
WHO BUT SO I THE FOLKS FROM?
THE LA COUNTY CAME TO MY OFFICE
AND SAT DOWN AND I REALLY --
I THINK THEY HAVE A GREAT SYSTEM
THERE AND YEAH IT'S DIFFERENT
FROM THE SYSTEM THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO HAVE HERE BECAUSE IT'S A
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT SO YOU
KNOW THEY HAVE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
MANY DIFFERENT SUPERVISORS IN
MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS.
AND THEY ALSO HAVE OF FIVE
PERSON BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THAT
IS AT THE TOP AYE I GUESS IS THE
LACK DID AND THEN THEY HAVE YOU
KNOW MANY --
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES THAT ARE
IN THERE COUNTY THAT ARE HAVE
ELECTED POSITIONS TO BUT IT IS
DIFFERENT THAN.
THE LEGISLATURE WHERE WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY AS A SENATOR
LEYVA IT.
SAID DIFFERENT BUSINESSES
BASICALLY AND AHEAD OF THAT IS
EACH ELECTED.
REPRESENTATIVE SO IT'S IT IS
DIFFERENT.
SO WE HAVE TO CRAFT THE POLICY
THAT -- HAS
TRUST AND HAS SOME.
ABILITY TO BE ABLE.
TO BRING ALL THE PEOPLE TO THE
TABLE AND IT IN AND IN A WAY
THAT.
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT.
ON IT AT THAT PROCESS IS NOT IS
FAIL PROOF SO IT WENT WHEN I HAD
LIKE A LITTLE MORE CLARIFICATION
ON HOW YOU.
SEE THIS PANEL OPERATING AND
THEN IF SOMEBODY CAME FOR WHAT
WOULD BE THE FINAL OUTCOME OF
THAT PANEL ON HOW HOW WOULD THAT
BE.
HANDLED.
WELL I WILL SAY FIRST THAT
GAINING TRUST I'M.
WERE PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
TRUST.
AND SOME OF OUR EMPLOYEES WE
KNOW.
DON'T DON'T TRUST US THAT'S
GONNA TAKE TIME AND THERE'S NO
POLICY WE'RE GOING TO PUT INTO
PLACE THAT'S GOING TO OVERNIGHT.
CHANGE THAT SO --
BUTTON I THINK YOU SEEN MAJOR
STEPS BEING TAKEN IS THE FIRST
STEP TOWARDS GETTING TRUST.
SEEING US PUT POLICIES INTO
PLACE THAT WE'RE WILLING TO BE
SUBJECTED.
TO AND THAT --
STARTS TO WORK.
AND WE WILL HAVE TO CUT WILL
HAVE TO EVALUATE YOU KNOW AS WE
PUT THIS INTO PLACE IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE ONE AND DONE YOU
KNOW THIS IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED.
TO KEEP A CLOSE EYE ON WE'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE TO TWEAK
IT FOR OUR ENVIRONMENT --
WE'LL DO A CULTURE SURVEY MAYBE
SIX MONTHS AFTER WE INSTITUTE
THE POLICIES AND GET A SENSE OF
OUR EMPLOYEES HOW IT'S WORKING
--
AND SO THAT WILL TAKE TIME.
I IN TERMS OF HOW THE PANEL
WORKS IT'S MY HOPE [inaudible]
THAT SUPERVISORS AND OTHERS IN
THE DECISION MAKING POSITIONS
WILL TAKE THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE PANEL VERY SERIOUSLY.
ARE THE PANEL ARE NOT EMPLOYEE
ARE NOT EMPLOYEES THERE UNDER
CONTRACT US BUT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE HOUSED.
HERE IN TERMS OF WORKING HERE SO
IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE FOR THEM I
THINK TO KIND OF HAVE CARTE
BLANCHE IN TO BE.
CHECKED IT SHOULD NOT BE THE TO
BE BEYOND IT MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
ULTIMATELY OF SUPERVISORS AT THE
EMPLOYEES THAT NEED TO ACT ON
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS.
THEY'RE NOT PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE
WORKING DAY TO DAY WITH THE
STAFF AND LA COUNTY THAT'S HOW
THEIR SYSTEM WORKS IN THIS IS
MODEL VERY MUCH ON THAT WERE
THEIR PANELS.
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS AND 98% OF
THE TIME THEY SAY THEY ARE
FOLLOWED BUT OCCASIONALLY A
SUPERVISOR WILL COME IN AND SAY.
HERE'S WHY WE HAVE TO TWEAK THIS
ARE HERE'S WHY WE DISAGREE AND
YOU KNOW BECAUSE THEIR THE PANEL
IS NOT THEIR DAY TO DAY TO TO BE
IN THOSE OFFICES.
BUT I IT'S MY HOPE THAT WE ALSO
HAVE A HIGH LEVEL OF AGREEMENT
AND CONSENSUS AND WORK WITH OUR
PANEL OTHERWISE THERE'S NOT MUCH
POINT TO HAVING THEM THERE IF WE
DON'T ACT ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
SENATOR MITCHELL HAD IN.
I HEAR YOUR QUESTION MISTER DALI
AND IT'S ABOUT ONE AND ONE THAT
WE CAN GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
TO WORK THROUGH.
AND I I MIGHT DISAGREE WITH YOU
A LITTLE I THINK WHILE LA
COUNTY'S NUMBERS ARE LARGER THE
DYNAMIC WITH THAT MADE IT
APPEALING I THINK FOR US.
AND OF ALL THE MODELS WE LOOKED
AT THE MOST RELEVANT IT WAS IT
WAS A WORK FOR AN ELECTED BODY.
SO EVEN THOUGH WE'RE ONE TWENTY
THEIR FIVE IT'S STILL THE
DYNAMIC OF THE WORK FORCE AN
ELECTED BODY.
AND THAT THEY'VE.
BEEN ABLE TO APPLY IT. TO THEIR
HIT OF OR UNIVERSE WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE IT'S SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT BECAUSE MANY.
OF THEIR EMPLOYEES ARE CIVIL
SERVANTS VERSUS OUR SERVER THE
PLEASURE BUT EVEN NAY THE
ELECTED.
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD HAVE
SEVERED THE PLEASURE PLEASE SO
AGAIN IT WAS A MODEL THAT WE
THOUGHT.
APPLY BECAUSE IT WOULD IMPACT
BOTH THE ELECTED [inaudible]
AND STAFF.
I THINK IT'S AGAIN WE'RE
CONTINUING TO ADD ME TO THIS.
SKELETON OF A FRAMEWORK --
AND THE PANEL WILL BE EMPOWERED.
TAKE THE INVESTIGATIONS AND MAKE
A RECOMMENDATION YOU HELD.
THAT THE WELL WE ARE
INCORPORATING THIS INTO AN
EXISTING KIND OF LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP FRAMEWORK SOME THAT'S
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT BETWEEN THE
TWO HOUSES BUT SENATE RULES IN
ASSEMBLY RULES.
SO WILL BE CONTINUING TO WORK ON
HOW WE INCORPORATE THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS INTO OUR
DECISION MAKING --
PROCESS AND BODY AS AN
INSTITUTION THAT'S THE WORK THAT
WE'RE CONTINUING TO LOOK AT AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT MAKES SENSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
DO YOU HAVE A FOLLOW UP TO I'M
SORRY I I DIDN'T LOOK BACK.
AT SOME OF THE RETALIATES SO.
THE GOAL OF THE GAME MY MIND IS
THAT.
WE WANT TO GET AS CLOSE. TO
PERFECT THE FIRST SHOT AS WE CAN
AND THAT SO THAT'S MY SOAP ON
THIS PANEL I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A VERY
NON PARTISAN NON POLITICAL
[inaudible]
ENVIRONMENT.
IN TERMS OF THE THE PANEL ITSELF
YOU AND JUST THE WHOLE PROCESS
BERMAN FOR MY LACK OF A BETTER
MEAN TO ME TO BETTER THE THE
BEST SCENARIO WOULD BE.
WHERE WE CAN GET THIS --
FOR REMOVED FROM POLITICS AND
PARTISANSHIP AS POSSIBLE AGREE
GO THAT'S THAT'S MY GOAL IS TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE DO THAT
--
AND HAVE INTEGRITY AND SO I'M SO
HOW THE PANEL GETS PICKED AND
HOW THE PANEL AND HOW.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS MOVE FORWARD
IF THE IF THERE'S AT THE YES I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
IF THE PANELISTS ALL.
OLD PEOPLE PICKED FROM THE
PUBLIC OR SOME FROM THE BOARD
FROM THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE IF
IT'S RULES THAT ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
SO THAT.
AND I CAN WEIGH IN ON WHETHER I
WAS SO MY GOAL IS TO GET IS THAT
IS.
FOR I WANT A NONPARTISAN NON
POLITICAL.
AND I DON'T WAS A MORE AT ALL H.
R. POLICIES FOR A WORKPLACE MUST
BE.
NO QUESTION NO QUESTION IN ANY
OF OUR MINDS --
WHEN THE WE HAVE ENGAGED IN
BEGUN TO PICK THE BRAIN OF THE
CHIEF JUSTICE?
FROM HER PERSPECTIVE TO WEIGH IN
ON IT WHAT IS SHE THINK IN TERMS
OF A PURELY --
LOOKING AT A PANEL OF INFORMED
PEOPLE WHO COULD PROVIDE US
GUIDANCE AND DIRECTION ON THE
FACT [inaudible] TO THEM.
PART OF FISH IT.
SHOULD NOT AND CANNOT PLAY A
ROLE IN ANY OF OUR HR PRACTICES.
OR POLICIES PLEASE NO QUESTION
AND SO WE'VE LOOKED AT A VARIETY
OF WAYS TO GET TO THESE FIVE
PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT NUMBER WOULD
BE APPOINTED BY WHAT GROUP.
AND HOW TO FRAME THAT AND AND
THERE'S BEEN OUTREACH TO HER TO
HAVE HER LOOK AT THIS NEW POLICY
WHERE DEVELOPING TO HAVE THE
SECRET COUNCILS WELL WE THOUGHT
SHE WAS THE MOST APPROPRIATE.
PERSON -- TO
DO THAT.
ALSO ANNA THAT I THINK WE SHOULD
CONSIDER ASKS TRYING TO SEE IF
ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SERVED SUCCESSFULLY ON THE PANEL
IN LA COUNTY COME AND BE PART OF
OUR AT LEAST OUR INITIAL PANEL.
TO HELP GIVE GUIDANCE TO THOSE
WHO ARE ARE STARTING A THING.
BECAUSE WE ALL S. THERE SEEMS TO
BE BROAD CONSENSUS AMONG THE
COMMITTEE HERE.
THAT LA COUNTY'S MODEL WORKS
WELL.
AND SO I THINK THAT WOULD HELP.
AS IN TERMS OF TRAINING OUR
PANEL.
I'M MOVING ON TO SENATOR BATES.
YEAH FINE AGAIN LET ME I ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF THE GRATITUDE
THANK YOU TO OUR CHAIRS AND
CERTAINLY TO THE STAFF.
I THINK THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE DO
STILL DISTILLATION IS THAT A
WORD OF GOD THE MANIA WEEKS I IN
INFORMATION THAT WAS BROUGHT
FORWARD TO ALL OF US ON THE
PANEL I WHEN I START GOING
THROUGH AND I THOUGHT.
HOW WE GONNA PUT THIS ALL
TOGETHER SO AYE AMAZING AYE JOB
I DO I WANT TO SPEAK AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I DON'T WE DID ABOUT THE
PANEL AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
FINE CERTAINLY A VERY CRITICAL?
COMPONENT OF THIS AND I KNOW.
THEIR PANELS OF THREE SEEM TO
DEVELOP A RELATIONSHIP AMONGST
THEM SO THAT THEY THEIR
DECISIONS WERE BASED ON A
UNANIMOUS ALL THREE SO I JUST
LIKE TO SUGGEST THAT.
WE MIGHT WANT TO HAVE. TWO
PANELS OF THREE SO WE HAVE SIX
RATHER THAN FIVE SWORE MOVING
THOSE PEOPLE IN AND OUT BECAUSE
YOU ALWAYS GET THREE AND THEN TO
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THE LAST
DECISION.
AND JUST TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
BECAUSE THEN YOU ARE COME IN MY
CONVERSATION WITH THEM SEEM TO
ME THAT THEY HAD.
THE THREE THREE AND THREE SO IF
THREE THAT SERVED ON THIS PANEL
A WERE NOT AVAILABLE THEY MOVED
TO PANEL B. OR C..
SO THAT THEY KEPT THE SAME THREE
PEOPLE TOGETHER AND I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT.
IS ACCURATE BUT IT'S SOMETHING
WE OUGHT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THEY'RE ALL.
KIND OF VIEWING THINGS ON YOU.
IF YOU HAVE TO HAVE THREE
UNANIMOUS DECISIONS I THINK THAT
THAT'S IMPORTANT YOU GET OF
FEELING AMONGST YOU ARE WHEN
YOU'RE WORKING TOGETHER ON
ISSUES LIKE THE IF THE OTHER
ITEM.
I IT'S NOT COVERED HERE BUT I
DON'T THINK WAS INTENDED TO BE
COVERED HERE BUT AGAIN IN THE
DISCUSSION.
I DO NOT REMEMBER WHAT.
WHAT THE NEXT STEP WAS AFTER IT
MOVED FROM HARASSMENT
INAPPROPRIATE TO PHYSICAL AND
THEN A FAULT BECAUSE?
I THINK PRESENTLY THAT
IMMEDIATELY GOES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT RATHER THEN THROUGH
OUR REVIEW PANEL FULL.
OP NOT THAT THAT WAS GOING TO BE
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT HERE TO
DO SOMETHING FOR US TO REMEMBER.
THAT THAT'S A DIFFERENT LEVEL
THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE.
REFERRED BEYOND THE PALACE AND
IF THEY COME WITHOUT.
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIECE THAT PROBABLY ISN'T
AN ISSUE BUT JUST TO PUT IT ON
OUR RADAR.
BUT THANK YOU AGAIN AND I THINK
GOD IT'S ALL BEEN.
EXCEPTIONAL ON THE JOB HIM INTO
A DAY OUT --
I'M NOT SURE WE UNDERSTOOD
INITIALLY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THAT CERTAINLY A WE DID AND IT
WAS NECESSARY FOR THANKS AGAIN.
WELL THANK YOU AND I I DO
BELIEVE THAT OF LOS ANGELES THEY
HAVE THEIR NINE PANELISTS AND
THEN THOSE PANELS OF THREE THEY
ROTATE THEM AROUND ACTUALLY NOT
THE SAME THING THAT THEY TRY TO
NOT HAVE THEM.
ALWAYS BE THE SAME PEOPLE.
I GUESS WITH ONLY NINE BECAUSE
THEY MEET TWICE A WEEK THEY END
UP THAT.
THEY WORK WITH EACH OTHER SO
OFTEN BUT THEY ARE WORKING WITH.
ALL OF THE ALL OF THE EIGHT
OTHER ONES FROM WEEK TO WEEK BUT
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO
THREE THREE THREE ONE YOU GOT.
FIVE YOU GOT PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE
DUPLICATED ON A PANEL FILLING IT
AND THAT'S ALL I'M THINKING.
FAIR ENOUGH YEAH THANK YOU YES.
IN TERMS OF CRIMINAL ACTION I
BELIEVE LA COUNTY REFERRERS TO
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IF
CRIMINAL ACTS --
IF IT IS BEEN DEEMED THAT A
CRIME WAS COMMITTED.
THAT I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
HAVE THAT EXPLICITLY STATED TO
ME THAT IN THE PARLOR WINDOWS
PROTECTIONS.
AND ALSO PAYS ATTENTION TO THE
PERPETRATOR GAS WHAT.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO THIS
NICE PANEL THING AND COME OUT IF
IF IT ACTUALLY STEPPED OVER THE
LINE GOT.
THANK YOU SEVEN MEMORY AS THANK
YOU I TO WANT TO JOIN THE REST
OF MY COLLEAGUES AND THINKING.
OF JERICHO CHAIR.
OF THE IT AND YOU'RE RIGHT MR.
WHERE I DON'T THINK I'VE SEEN
ANY ABSENCES AND I APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK WE'LL TOOK THIS?
VERY SERIOUSLY WE KNEW IT WAS
SOMETHING IMPORTANT AND WE WANT
TO BE ENGAGED --
AND I DON'T THINK WE CAN
OVERSTATE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
HEARINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING
AND TODAY'S VERY SPECIFIC.
ONE IF IF WE ARE GOING TO MAKE
CHANGE. TO THE INSTITUTION TO
RESPOND TO THE HARASSMENT I
THINK WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH WHAT
IS HAPPENING INSIDE.
AND OUTSIDE.
AND WHAT THE QUESTIONS ALLOW STE
AND I ASKED THE QUESTION
REGARDING THE LOBBYISTS AND THE
OUTSIDE --
HARASSMENT BECAUSE THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT.
SURPRISED ME QUITE FRANKLY.
THAT THAT WAS A FINDING THAT
SURPRISED ME AND SO I WANT TO BE
SURE THAT.
IN OUR IT THE WAY WE ADDRESS
THIS I DO WANT TO BE SURE THAT
WE HAVE.
SOMETHING THAT ADDRESSES IT THE
HARASSMENT THAT OUR STAFF FEELS
FROM OUTSIDE SOURCES WITH OUR BE
LOBBYISTS OR THE PUBLIC --
I AM VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE.
BUT OUR OUR OUR EMPLOYEES WITH
ONE ANOTHER HAVE WONDERFUL
RELATIONSHIPS AND THEY DO FEEL
THEY CAN TRUST THEIR
SUPERVISORS.
IT'S THE PROCESS.
THAT I BELIEVE THAT'S WHERE WE
BREAK IT WERE WERE ALL
COMMUNICATION BREAKS DOWN
BECAUSE THEY DON'T TRUST THE
PROCESS.
AND IS GOING BACK TO THE CULTURE
THAT WE'VE ALL TALKED ABOUT SO I
THINK THAT THAT.
THE TRAINING.
I DON'T THINK THAT THERE'S AS
MUCH OF A COMPLAINT REGARDING
THE TRAINING IT'S WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THE REPORT IS MADE.
AND KNOWING THAT SOMETHING IS
GOING TO COME FROM THAT SO I
THINK THAT THIS ENTIRE PROCESS
OF OF THE PANEL AND SUBJECT
MATTER MEMBERS.
IS SO IMPORTANT AND I AND I AM
VERY GRATEFUL TO LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FOR SHARING THAT
EXPERIENCE WITH US.
AND I AM VERY GRATEFUL THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE ALL SAW.
AS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN EMULATE
IN THE BEGINNING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE BEGIN TO GAIN THAT TRUST.
THAT THE INSTITUTION DOES NOT
HAVE -- WITH
OUR WORKERS WHEN THEY DO GIVE
THEIR COMPLAINTS.
I AM LOOKING FORWARD.
TO THE NEXT UP WITHOUT A DOUBT
WE KNOW IT'S GOT TO BE A
HOLISTIC APPROACH --
THAT WILL COVER ALL THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FOR OUR FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES WHERE THE EMPLOYEES OF
THE LEGISLATURE SO I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A SUMMER WALTER.
THANK MADAM CHAIR --
DID ALL THE COMMENTS OF EVERYONE
SO FAR -- I
THINK IT'S GREAT THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER ON THIS
ISSUE -- AS
DEEP IN ISSUE IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE AS IT IS --
THE OTHER THING IS THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE A A PROCESS THAT'S BEEN
WORKING AND IS KIND OF BEEN
VETTED THROUGH IN.
LOS ANGELES IS HELPING US TAKE A
STEP UP SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
REINVENT THE WHEEL.
AND WE CAN LOOK AT IT YOU KNOW
WHAT MAKES US DIFFERENT.
AS OPPOSED TO YOU KNOW HOW THEY
RUN THEIR OPERATION AND WE ARE
DIFFERENT AND THOSE THINGS WILL
EVOLVE AS WE WORK ON IT.
I JUST HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
REALLY BRIEF --
ON THE YOU KNOW THE THE GOAL OF
HAVING PEOPLE FEEL COMFORTABLE
TO REPORT AND ENCOURAGING PEOPLE
TO REPORT.
PHAM WHAT HAPPENS IN ON LOOKING
AT THIS THE HAND THAT WE HAVE --
ON SECTION. THREE FOR TALKS
ABOUT THE SYSTEM REPORTS
IMMEDIATELY BY SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS.
SO IF ARE YOU.
REPORT A CLAIM.
AT WHAT POINT TO I GET ANY
STATUS BACK OR IS THERE A CASE
NUMBER ASSIGNED OR MAYBE A FEW
NO IS IT MORE --
CONFIDENTIAL IN THAT THEY GET A
CASE NUMBER AND NOT THEIR NAME
ALWAYS ASSOCIATED OR WHAT KIND
OF TRACK IS OUR TRACKING NUMBER.
YOU KNOW CAN IS THERE SOME WAY
SOMEONE CAN SIGN ON AND LOOKED
TO SEE GENE OKAY NOW IT'S BEEN
ASSIGNED TO INVESTIGATE OR
STATUS.
PENDING MORE AT WHAT THE YOU
KNOW WHAT WILL POINT TO THE GET
UPDATES OR DO THEY HAVE TO WAIT
ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
JUST THANK YOU.
FOR SUBMITTING AND THEN NOTHING
UNTIL THE END.
I'M JUST CURIOUS HOW HOW THAT'S
HANDLED.
I WOULD SAY THAT THAT YOU KNOW
THE ROLE OF CREATING THIS NEW
INVESTIGATIVE UNIT WILL ALSO BE
TO EMPOWER THEM TO INFORM US ON
THE DRILL DOWN IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS SETTING POLICY
SAYING.
WE WANT EMPLOYEES TO BE IN
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS.
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT FRANKLY
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR US TO GET
TO A LEVEL OF DETAIL WILL WE'RE
GONNA SAY AND THIS IS HOW YOU'LL
DO IT MISTER MISS INVESTIGATOR
ASSIGNING CASE NUMBER BLAHBLAH
BLAH I THINK THOSE ARE.
THINGS THAT WE CAN SAY TO THEM
BUT AGAIN I THINK.
OUR ROLE HOPEFULLY WILL BE TO
ESTABLISH THIS UNIT WHERE --
OUR GOALS ARE EXPECTATIONS OF
THE OUTCOME I THINK THE HOW WILL
BE LEFT UP TO THAT UNIT TO
INFORM US IN TERMS OF BEST
PRACTICES OUT ENOUGH CASE
NUMBERS IS THE BEST WAY TO DO
IT.
THAT'S WHY WE WANTED A HIRE
INVESTIGATORS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE TO PROVIDE US WITH.
CLEAR FOR CATION SUGGESTIONS ON
THE BEST WAY TO IMPLEMENT I
DON'T KNOW THAT WOULD BE THE WAY
THAT THEY WOULD ADVISE THAT WE
DO IT YEAH YOU KNOW WE'RE CLEAR
AS WE HEARD THROUGH THE HEARING
PROCESS THAT.
THAT ON ANONYMITY IS SOMETHING
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
REALITY IN TERMS OF PEOPLE
WANTING TO COME FOR BUT NOT
WILLING.
TO NAME SO IT WILL BE UP TO
THOSE INVESTIGATORS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO CREATE THAT BALANCE
BUT I THINK.
WE WILL SEND THEM THE MESSAGE
LOUD AND CLEAR THAT WE NEED
EMPLOYEES INFORMED ABOUT THE
PROCESS AS APPROPRIATE.
THROUGHOUT NINE YEAH ABSOLUTELY
PEOPLE WILL BE INFORMED.
AS SENATOR MITCHELL SAID WE
DON'T HAVE THE DETAILS OF HOW
THAT'S GOING YOU KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THAT PROCESS WILL BE BUT IT
WON'T BE THE CASE THAT PEOPLE
SUBMIT A REPORT YOU KNOW UNDER
THEIR NAME AND DON'T HEAR BACK
FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS I MEAN WE
WILL LET THEM.
KNOW WHAT THE TRIAGE SORT OF IN
YEAH SAYS AND AND THEN SOME
EXPECTATION OF TIME AND
CERTAINLY WHEN THERE'S BEEN A
RESPONSE THEY'LL BE NOTIFIED
THAT THERE'S BEEN A RESPONSE.
I AND WE ALSO JUST BECAUSE WE
HAVE I DIDN'T SAY IT IN MY
PRESENTATION WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING.
ANONYMOUS COMPLAINTS AND WE WILL
INVESTIGATE THOSE TO THE BEST OF
OUR ABILITY WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY AS AN EMPLOYER.
TO INVESTIGATE ARE ALL
COMPLAINTS ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OTHER TYPES OF
DISCRIMINATION SO THOSE WILL BE
INVESTIGATED BUT CLEARLY IN THAT
CASE THERE'S NO ONE TO REPORT
BACK.
TO OKAY --
AND THEN.
JUST THIS MAY BE JUST A
TECHNICAL.
YOU JUST CERTAIN NOT EVEN A TYPO
BUT MORE OF THE WAY IT WAS
WORDED.
THE ACTUAL --
DRAFT OF POLICY.
ON THE C. FUND PAID SEVEN AND
OUR HAND THOUGH [inaudible]
SAYS [inaudible]
THAT WHERE'S WE HAVE SO MANY
PAPERS HERE.
THAT THE SUPERVISOR.
A PAID SEVEN AT THE BOTTOM IT'S
A SUPERVISORS INCLUDING MEMBERS
MUST REPORT ANY COMPLAINTS OF
MISCONDUCT. TO THE WORKPLACE
CONDUCT UNIT IMMEDIATELY.
BUT YET IN OUR THE HANDLE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON PAGE TWO IT'S
A SUIT SUPERVISORS SHOULD REPORT
AND IT MAY JUST BE SEMANTICS I
MEAN I WOULD GO WITH THE POLICY
WHAT THAT SAYS.
THAT THE REPORT NOT THAT THEY
SHOULD.
BUT WAS OKAY ON THEN REALLY
QUICKLY MOVE NUMBER THAT JUST
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS OF
HOPEFULLY WILL BE BRIEF --
WE'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT HOW IN
THAT GOES BACK TO WHAT WAS SAID
ABOUT --
WHEN THINGS ARE DISCLOSED THAT
THE HOUSE OF BASICALLY RULES?
WILL RELEASE CERTAIN DOCUMENTS
IN CASES WHERE THE PANEL
DETERMINES THAT FACTS RELATED TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT CLAIMS HAVE
BEEN SUBSTANTIATED.
AGAINST A MEMBER OR A HIGH LEVEL
LEGISLATIVE.
EMPLOYEES SO ONCE IT'S GONE
THROUGH THAT INDEPENDENT.
PANEL THEY'VE MADE A
RECOMMENDATION FOUND IT TO BE
SUBSTANTIVE.
THEN RIGHT NOW OUR POLICY DRAFT
IS STATING THAT IT COMES BACK TO
RULES WILL DETERMINE IF THEY
ACCEPT OR NOT ACCEPT.
AND THAT ONE POINT THAT WOULD
BECOME PUBLIC IF IT'S
SUBSTANTIATED [inaudible]
I'M.
IF THEY IF SAY RULES DECIDES NOT
TO ACCEPT.
EVEN THOUGH THE CAN THE PANEL
SAYS IT'S SUBSTANTIATED.
SHOULD I WOULD ASSUME BE STILL
MADE PUBLIC BECAUSE THEN.
RULES WOULD HAVE TO STTE WHY.
DECLINED AT SOME POINT IT WOULD
HAVE TO BE.
BECAUSE AND IT GOES BACK TO THE
CONCERN.
OF BEING POLITICAL YOU KNOW IF
WE COULD KEEP IT AS MUCH AS
ARM'S LENGTH.
IT'S SHOULD ALMOST BE IF IT
COMES BACK FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THAT THE UNIT AS BEING
SUBSTANTIATE IT MUST BE MET OR
SHOULD BE MADE PUBLIC JUST TO BE
CLEAR THERE'S TWO SEPARATE PARTS
TO WHAT THE PANEL WILL BE
LOOKING AT ONE IS WHETHER IT'S A
VIOLATION OF OUR POLICY.
AND AT WHAT LEVEL.
THAT IF IT'S DETERMINED THAT IT
WAS A VIOLATION OF OUR SEXUAL
HARASSMENTPOLICY. FOR SENIOR
STAFF AND MEMBERS THAT WILL BE
THIS SECOND PART IS THE
RECOMMENDED ACTIONS THE
RECOMMENDED ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES AND THAT BY OUR POLICY
DOES NOT HAVE TO BE DISCLOSED.
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT WILL GO
BACK TO THE EACH REPRESENTATIVE
EACH OF SEPARATE HOUSE FOR
DETERMINATION OF WHETHER.
TO BASICALLY FOLLOW THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO THE
DISCIPLINE OR THE RESPONSE.
SO THAT THEY CAN THEY PANEL
WOULD SAY THESE OF SUBSTANTIATED
THAT IT WOULD BE MADE PUBLIC OF
THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT SUIT
[inaudible]
INSTANTIATED THEN.
THE HOUSE RULES WOULD SAY THEY
ACCEPT OR REJECT. FOR SENIORS
OFTEN FOR MEMBERS THAT'S THAT'S
MY RECOMMENDATION --
THAT'S THE RECOMMENDATION AND
I'M PUTTING FORWARD TO ALL OF
YOU THAT THAT THAT THERE'S THIS
TWO SEPARATE ELEMENTS ONE IS THE
DETERMINATION OF WHETHER IT WAS
A VIOLATION OF POLICY AND IF SO
WHAT LEVEL IS A JUST A VIOLATION
OF ARE.
INTERNAL COULD CONDUCT OR DOES
IT RISE TO THE LEVEL OF ACTUAL
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND IT'S THOSE
THAT RISE TO THAT LEVEL OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THAT WOULD BE DISCLOSED TO THE
PRESS THE SECOND PART IS THE
PANEL WITH THAT ALSO SAY.
THIS WAS A VIOLATION OF POLICY
AT SUCH AND SUCH A LEVEL AN HOUR
RECOMMENDED RESPONSES AND I
WOULD THINK WITH MEMBERS YOU
KNOW IT IT MAY NOT BE SO
SPECIFIC IT MIGHT JUST BE
TRAINING.
OR MIGHT BE SOME LEVEL OF
DISCIPLINE TO BE DETERMINED.
WHATEVER THAT THEN GOES TO THE
RESPECTIVE HOUSES TEND TO TO
IMPLEMENT OKAY.
GOOD BECAUSE YET AND I WASN'T
SURE ABOUT THAT SO FOR
CLARIFICATION IT HELPS BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT THE POLITICS TO PLAY
IN THE MIDDLE WHAT GETS THE
SCHOOLS AND WHAT THOSE.
THAT THAT WAS THE BIGGEST
QUESTION I HAVE HOME QUICKLY --
IF THE RULES COMMITTEE --
DEVIATES FROM WHAT THE PANEL
RECOMMENDS --
DOES.
DOES THE ACCUSER OR DOES THE THE
VICTIM BASICALLY GET TO KNOW
[inaudible]
THAT.
BUT WHAT POINT.
AND YOU KNOW AND RESOLUTION OF
THIS WOULD THE ACTUAL COMPLAINT
AND GET TO KNOW WHAT THE RESULT
WAS AS FAR AS THE PUNISHMENT.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT --
WHAT'S DISCLOSED TO THE
REPORTING PARTY IS PROBABLY
GOING TO VARY DEPENDING ON THE
TYPE OF INCIDENT THAT IT IS.
WHAT'S APPROPRIATE AND WHAT'S
NOT I THINK IT'S I I PERSONALLY
THINK IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
MAKE A POLICY THAT SAYS.
IN EVERY CASE WHAT VICTIMS WILL
BE TOLD HIM WHAT THEY WANT YOU
KNOW THERE'S THERE'S
CONFIDENTIALITY ISSUES THERE'S
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER ISSUES
BUT THEY WILL KNOW THAT THERE
HAS BEEN A RESPONSE THEY WILL
KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN
INVESTIGATION --
THEY WILL KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
THE COMPLAINTS SUBSTANTIATED
THAT THEY WILL ABSOLUTELY NO IN
TERMS OF THE RESPONSE YOU KNOW
MOST OF MOST OF THE COMPLAINTS
THAT ARE GOING TO COME IN ARE
NOT.
PROBABLY GONNA BE.
MET YOU KNOW EMPLOYEE TO
EMPLOYEE AND THERE'S ALSO THERE
IS SOME CONFIDENTIALITY THAT HAS
TO BE WEIGHED IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE YOU MAY IT MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE TO GO TO SOMEONE WHO
COMPLAIN AND SAY YES IT WAS
SUBSTANTIATED.
AND THEY'RE GETTING FOUR DAYS OF
TRAINING AND YOU KNOW THAT
THERE'S A CERTAIN LEVEL I THINK
WE HAVE TO SORT OF SEPARATE THAT
IN SOME THINGS WILL BE --
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THAT WHETHER
THERE WAS AN INCIDENT WHETHER IT
WAS A VIOLATION OF POLICY WILL
BE DISCLOSED.
SO THEY WOULD GET AT LEAST THIS
IS NOT YOU KNOW THE RESOLUTION.
ALL BUT NOT NECESSARILY THE
DETAIL YEAH WILL BE TOLD THAT
HAS BEEN RESOLVED THERE'S BEEN
THERE'S BEEN A RESPONSE.
AND THAT I THINK THAT'S IN
KEEPING WITH WHAT PROBABLY WHAT
MOST EMPLOYERS AND OF DOING
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
THE ALLEGATION INCIDENT HEARD IT
WAS A VIOLATION OF OUR POLICY
AND WE HAVE RESPONDED
ACCORDINGLY.
YES SENATOR MITCH I'M I'M GONNA
LET HER SKIP THE PLEASE FORGIVE
ME COLLEAGUES IM GONNA ASK YOUR
INDULGENCE ALLOW ME TO SKIP THE
LINE I SHOULD BE GAMBLING DOWN
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE IN LESS
THAN A MINUTE.
SO LET ME I'M JUST QUICKLY SAY I
WANT TO THANK ON THE SENATE SIDE
THE STAFF JUST IN DIANNE WHO
PUT.
COUNTLESS OF OURS IN THEIR
ATTENTION TO DETAIL INTO THIS
PROCESS.
THE ONE THING I DIDN'T WANT US.
TO TO LEAVE ALL HERE WITHOUT --
AT LEAST BEGINNING TO TALK
ABOUT.
ARE TO THE CLIMATE SATURDAY AND
HOW WE ROLE THAT OUT AND SHARE
IT WITH THE EMPLOYEES WHO THE
DATA IS THERE THAT THERE CLIMATE
SURVEY.
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT NEXT
STEPS PER SE BUT ONE SUGGESTION
I WOULD MAKE. FOR FOLLOW UP IS
THAT PARTICULARLY DO YOU KNOW TO
HONOR WHAT WE HEARD EMPLOYEE
SANTAM THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEIR DIRECT SUPERVISOR.
IS IN THE NEXT CHIEFS OF STAFF
UPDATE WHICH PERHAPS COULD BEAT
CHAIRED THAT THE CHIEF OF STAFF
ARE GIVEN THE FOLD OUT AND WE
ASK THE CHIEFS. TO THE END ROLE
THAT OUT TO ALL OF THEIR TEAM
MEMBERS --
WOULDN'T TALK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
NEXT STEPS BUT IT BUT THAT WOULD
BE THE SUGGESTION I MAKE IN
TERMS OF HOW.
THAT THE EMPLOYEES DATA ROLLS
OUT TO THE EMPLOYEES.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU AND I KNOW WE HAVE
SENATOR MORE LOCKING THAT WE DO
OF THE PUBLIC TO HEAR FROM AS
WELL SO I'M GONNA GO TO SENATOR
MORE LOCKING MAYBE ASK MY
COLLEAGUES MUCH OF ANYTHING
PRESSING TO WAIT UNTIL WE ARE
FOR THE PUBLIC.
IN THAT WE CAN FINISH UP.
THANK YOU SENATOR TO MAKE YOU
THINK YOU MATTER CHERRY --
WE HAVE THIS SLIDE IT SAYS
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IF I PLAY BACK THE TAPE I HEARD
THIS IS THE NEW.
POLICY AND SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
WHAT IS OUR COMMITTEE ROLE NOW.
DO WE VOTE ON IT WE HAVE SOME
BILLS IN THE LEGISLATURE TO DEAL
WITH.
PARTICULAR TOPIC ARE WE DOING A
BILL --
ORDERS THIS ADMINISTRATIVELY
JUST HANDLED BY EACH.
OF THE HOUSES RULES COMMITTEES
THEY JUST.
PUT FIVE IS.
YEAH NOW UP THE PROCESS
QUESTIONS YEAH I KNOW THE
GOVERNMENT SECTOR GOING TO BE ON
THE INDEPENDENT PANEL --
WHAT'S THE SELECTION AND
COMPENSATION PROCESS --
AT THE COUNTY OF ORANGE RED
SOMETHING SIMILAR BUT THEY WERE
INTERNALLY WERE DEPARTMENT
HEADS.
COUNTY COUNCIL.
A SAWED.
MAYBE THAT YOU CAN GIVE US LATER
WELL I'LL TO START BACKWARDS
QUICKLY THAT THE PANEL WERE
STILL DISCUSSING HOW THEY'RE
GONNA BE APPOINTED AND WHO AND
BY WHOM WERE SPEAKING TO THE
CHIEF JUSTICE FOR INSTANCE AND
SO THAT'S UNDER DISCUSSION.
THEY WILL NOT BE EMPLOYEES THEY
WILL BE UNDER CONTRACT THEY WILL
BE COMPENSATED IN SOME WAY --
WE THE NEW THE CREATING THE
BICAMERAL UNIT WILL BE A NEW.
TO AND THE LEGISLATURE AND THEY
WILL BE FUNDED AND THEY WILL BE
STAFFED TO WHAT LEVEL WE DON'T
KNOW WHEN THAT COULD CHANGE OVER
TIME IF WE FEEL THAT WE NEED
MORE PEOPLE IN THAT DEPARTMENT
BUT THAT WILL BE A NEW BY CAROL
DEPARTMENT UNDER LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL.
UNDER THAT UMBRELLA BUT IT WILL
BE A SEPARATE UNIT.
SO I WOULD OFF SO THAT THEY CAN
OPERATE INDEPENDENTLY --
IN TERMS OF PROCESS.
TODAY WE'RE WE'RE I'M HEARING
FROM ALL OF YOU WE WILL MEET ON
THURSDAY FOR US.
TO MAKE ANY CHANGES TO THIS
POLICY THAT WE SEE FIT BASED ON
YOUR COMMENTS WE WILL VOTE ON
IT.
IT WILL THEN GO TO JOINT RULES
NEXT WEEK TO BE ADOPTED FOR THAT
BY THEM WE DO NOT NEED
LEGISLATION FOR THIS THIS IS AN
INTERNAL POLICY.
SO ONCE JOINT RULES ADOPTS IT OR
ANY MAKES ANY CHANGES THAT THEY
WANT TO MAKE AND VOTES ON IT
WILL BECOME.
THE NEW POLICIES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
I IN TERMS OF BILLS.
FROM THERE RIGHT NOW MAYBE BILLS
THAT IMPACT THOSE --
NOT FROM US BUT THERE ARE
OUTSIDE MEMBERS WHO MIGHT VERY
WELL BE DOING.
BILLS THAT WOULD CHANGE THIS I
HOPE THAT THEY'RE NOT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT WE WENT THROUGH A
VERY PUBLIC PROCESS TO GET TO
THIS PLACE.
AND SOMEONE COMING IN KIND OF
FROM THE SIDE SAYING WELL I'M
GONNA UNDERMINE ALL OF THAT AND
YOU KNOW.
JUST TAKE IT TO THE FLOOR FOR A
VOTE UP I WOULD THINK IS A NOT
VERY HELPFUL. TO THIS PROCESS --
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE POLICY AYE
THAT'S YOUR PROCEDURAL STEPS
FROM HERE.
SO THAT I'D LIKE TO GO TO OF TO
THE PUBLIC TO HEAR FROM THEM.
LET THEM LINE UP.
IT IS ONLY ONE OR TWO OF YOU
YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME UP TO THE
PODIUM THE TABLE
.
SAMANTHA CORRAN ON BEHALF OF
LEAST ENOUGH TODAY I'M JUST LIKE
TO THANK THE CO CHAIRS FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK
STAFF AS WELL.
I'M QUITE A FEW MAN HOURS HAVE
BEEN SPENT ON THIS EFFORT.
AYE SINCE OUR LETTER LAST
OCTOBER WE'VE HEARD FROM ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND PUBLIC SERVANTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BUT LITERALLY
ALSO ACROSS THE WORLD.
AND WHILE MANY OF THEM HAVE
SHARED STORIES WITH US ALL OF
THEM ARE WATCHING TO SEE WHAT
CALIFORNIA DOES NEXT SO WE JUST
WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL EFFORTS HERE AND AND
AGAIN THE VOLUME OF TIME AND
SERIOUSNESS THAT YOU PUT IN. TO
DOING THIS WORK IN AND PUTTING
FORWARD RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE KNOW THIS IS A VERY
CHALLENGING WORK.
ON IT PRESENTS N AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT BOTH
IN WORD AND INDEED A TRULY
INDEPENDENT PROCESSES
ESTABLISHED BUT PEOPLE CONTRAST.
I'M IT SO EQUALLY IF NOT MORE
IMPORTANT WILL BE ENSURING AND
ARTICULATING TO LEGISLATIVE
STAFF THAT THIS IS A FAIR
PROCESS WHICH WILL PLEASE EQUITY
IN SAFETY ABOUT POLITICS.
AND IS NOT BEHOLDEN TO THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY THIS IS GOING
TO NEED TO BE DEMONSTRATED TO
LEGISLATIVE STAFF THROUGH
TRANSPARENCY AND OBJECTIVE CAN
[inaudible]
SEE ON THESE ARE POINTS I KNOW
YOU KNOW --
AND AND CERTAINLY A LOT EASIER
FOR US TO SAY TO YOU AND THEN TO
IMPLEMENT.
WE'VE HEARD FROM A LOT OF STAFF
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS.
ON THERE'S A MIX OF SORT OF
ENTHUSIASM SKEPTICISM AYE AND
CERTAINLY FEAR.
YOU ARE BLESSED TO HAVE
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF PUBLIC
POLICY EXPERTS AS YOUR STAFF.
PLEASE USE THEM.
AS PART OF THIS PROCESS LAW
INCLUDING STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS
AS YOU ADD NEED TO THE BONES AT
TO TAKE A PAGE FROM.
SENATOR MITCHELL AND BEGIN TO
IMPLEMENT THAT WILL BE ESSENTIAL
TO NOT ONLY ENSURING THEIR BUY
IN AND TRUST IN THE PROCESS BUT
FRANKLY WE BELIEVE WILL RESULT.
IN THE BEST PROCESS --
SOME MAY HAVE BEEN SURPRISED TO
SEE THE HIGH INCIDENCE OF
COMPLAINTS REGARDING LOBBYISTS
AND THOSE OUTSIDE THE BUILDING.
WE WERE NOT --
AS THIS PROCESS MOVES FORWARD WE
CALL ON OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
THIRD HOUSE TO SUPPORT YOUR WORK
AND TO PARTICIPATE IN CRAFTING A
COMMUNITY WIDE SOLUTION WITH THE
NECESSARY JURISDICTION TO HOLD
EVERYONE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
BEHAVIOR --
LOBBYISTS MUST ASPIRE TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION IN CHANGING THE
CULTURE AND NOT PART OF THE
PROBLEM SO FOR HOUSE WE HAVE TO
DO BETTER AS WELL.
AND THINK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE THE SPAR WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU AS WE
MOVE FORWARD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M JIM WHEN BURGER ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA ARE.
VERY IMPRESSED WITH THE
PROPOSALS AND ONE AFFECT
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR FOR YOUR
WORK ON THAT'S WITH REGARDS --
TO THE LOWER LEVEL CONTACT THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF CRIMINAL BUT JUST THE
SAME NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH
EARLY ON AND WE REALLY.
APPRECIATED THAT DOUG YOU'RE
REALLY LOOKING AT RECOGNIZING
THESE PROPER --
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT --
THE INCLUSION OF ALTERNATIVE --
RESPONSES AND THE MENTION OF
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE WHICH IS
SOMETHING WE CARE VERY DEEPLY
ABOUT IT FCL --
WE DO THINK THAT --
WHEN CONDUCTING RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE --
PROCESSES THAT WHENEVER POSSIBLE
IT SHOULD INVOLVE --
V. AGGRESSOR OR OR THE
PERPETRATOR THEY NEED TO BE PART
OF THAT --
IN ORDER TO GET THE FULLY
TRANSFER FORMATIVE A FACT THAT
DOES REQUIRE THEM TO ACCEPT AT
LEAST SOME LEVEL OF
RESPONSIBILITY --
BEFORE PARTICIPATING.
IN HIM DOES THAT KIND OF
DIALOGUE --
WERE HAPPY TO HELP THE COMMITTEE
AND ASSIST WITH THAT ANYWAY WE
CANNOT SO IT DOES NEED TO BE
FACILITATED DOES HAVE TO INVOLVE
TRAINING.
IS NOT JUST TO PEOPLE GETTING
INTO A ROOM AND AND AND TALKING
ABOUT IT BUT IT DOES REQUIRE
SOME COACHING AND TRAINING AND
FACILITATION AND SO FORTH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WILL COME BACK TO
THE PANEL IF THERE'S ANY CLOSING
REMARKS MANY BODY MISTER DALI.
THE MINIATURE STILL JUST ONE OF
THE LET YOU KNOW ABOUT MY
CONCERNS I'M VERY MUCH CONCERNED
ABOUT THE APPOINTEES AND WHO
APPOINTS THEM AND HOW WE KEEP
THAT -- NON
POLITICAL AND THEN ALSO
[inaudible]
IF.
I'M NOT TRYING TO MAKE SURE I SO
THAT THERE'S NO OPPORTUNITY --
FOR SOMEBODY IN ELECTED OFFICE
TO BE ABLE.
TO GARDER HIDE SOME.
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
DELIGHTED OUT FROM SO.
AND THEN ALSO ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
IT'S NOT ABUSED IN THE OTHER
DIRECTION TOO SO I'M I'M A
LITTLE BIT CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
WE GET.
TO THE PANEL AND HOW THAT PANEL
THEN --
OPERATE SO I WILL THEM.
DIG A LITTLE DEEPER ON AND HOW I
THINK WE WE SHOULD GET THERE AND
I'M HOPING THAT TIME.
WE COULD HAVE THAT DISCUSSION --
BETWEEN NOW AND NEXT WEEK THAT
WHEN WE GET WE FIGURE OUT A WAY.
TO TO GET IT IS FURTHER AWAY
WITH KEEPING A SECURE WHERE WE
WE HAVE NO OPPORTUNITY FOR
PARTISANSHIP OR LARA ARE NOT
NONPARTISAN I SHOULD SAY WHERE
IT WHERE WE DON'T HAVE POLITICAL
--
IMPLICATIONS [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY.
ASSISTANT CITY AND ALSO THE
PERCEPTION AND THE REALITY OF AN
UNBIASED PROCESS AND A PROCESS
THAT'S FAIR TO BOTH PEOPLE THAT
ARE BEING ACCUSED AND PEOPLE WHO
ARE MAKING --
A REPORTING INCIDENTS --
IS THE FOUNDATION OF WHAT WILL
MAKE THIS WORK SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONCERNS I THANK YOU FOR
VOICING THEM I'M CERTAINLY
AVAILABLE TO CONTINUE DISCUSSION
BETWEEN NOW AND THURSDAY.
AND HOPEFULLY BY THEN WILL HAVE
WORKED SOME OF THESE ISSUES OUT
TO YOUR SATISFACTION AND THAT
WOULD BE MY GOAL.
WITH THAT I WILL --
I THANK EVERYBODY WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY WE WILL BE
BACK AGAIN ON THURSDAY --
TO TO BE VOTING ON THE FINAL
RECOMMENDATIONS --
AND WITHOUT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED